bien j'accueille tout de suite michèle
bernier
oui
catherine barma qui me dit un petit mot
à miller j'ai peur qu'il fasse la gueule
je les vexer même si j'attendais le
moment où je pourrais parler avec linda
donc j'attendais que vous terminiez il
veut tout de suite de son ancien trader
qui a coûté laurel et hardy les invités
gérard bizette on est revenus sur
l'essentiel donc j'attendais que vous
ayez fini ça y est c'est terminé c'est
une surprise avait line l'art donc
finalement dans cette émission vous
savez pourquoi on la regarde
pour vous c'est pour moi regarde donc il
ya un moment donné où il va falloir
conclure ça vous a jamais eu au
téléphone 7 6 mais c'est ce que j'essaie
d'obtenir des données la fin pour qu'il
reste jusqu'à la fin de l'émission les
invasions départ l'année
méfiez-vous à quand une quand on t'a de
téléphone pour une miss france et trois
fois en 65 minutes d'avancé un petit peu
dans cette émission oui oui thierry eux
et donc on va regarder c'est une
tradition on va regarder le best of de
la semaine dernière magnéto serge nikto
fob ni la phobie nique non est ce que
vous êtes benno non baîllonné folle
oui alors c'est la peur de bruno bellone
c'est vrai que cette histoire elle elle
et elle est mal parti allait mal parti
et puis après j'ai mal il n'a pas besoin
de publicité
ça pulse t il à cette publicité il est
archi connus et pour moi ce qui est
important c'est que ce gamin là je veux
pas qu'on crie je voulais dire que
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup d'amis beurre
beaucoup beaucoup d'amis frikha que j'ai
vécu des moments absolument magnifique
avec eux que j'en vis toujours et que je
souhaite que ça dure le plus longtemps
possible et que je suis bien embêté de
tout ça je crois que je suis pas le seul
parce que ça pourrait donner une image
il faut pas qu'elle existe cette image
il faut la paix faut la paix la paix
absolument la paix absolument la paix la
fraternité absolument absolument c'est
la seul message à faire passer c'est la
seule chose qu soit digne de vivre et
qu'il faut absolument vivre dans la
dignité
on est des frères on est pas on a des
confessions différentes on a des façons
de vivre différentes nom et des frais on
est des humains sur cette planète a été
déglingué par d'autres que ceux sur
lesquels on voudrait aujourd'hui jeter
l'anathème le truc le plus dur vous avez
fait tous les deux mois je faisais
images jongler avec des poules mais
entre les chansons et
aujourd'hui c'est la bonne vie vous avez
un cabriolet mercedes vous donner des
coups de pied vous passez vos
anniversaires avec christine bravo qui
est super sympa et gilbert montagné
qu'est ce qu'il ya de mieux dans la vie
que passer à faire avec les chinois vont
évidemment tanière
si vous souhaitez rencontrer une rouge
sa forte poitrine qui a beaucoup de
thunes une mercedes et qui sera vous
défendre contre les méchants dans la rue
tout le monde en parle qui transmettra
si vous aviez une baguette magique vous
changeriez courant vous pour le fun il
veut les laisser répondre à olivier
becker
vas-y vas-y le week-end je veux je
connais yahvé barclays qui vous est lavé
ses chemises avec ça ces tâches de
mousse au chocolat comme ça et après
vous file edi sac parce que vous aviez
nettoyer ses chemises et les mêmes
départ tous dans le resto ont nettoyé
auger a est influencé par la philosophie
bouddhiste ça moi vous êtes mi-régimes
nestea ouais qu'est ce qui vous fascine
dans l'univers féminin justement vous
qu'être fasciné par l'univers féminin
qui rosissent un peu comme ça mais qui
rosissent quand on leur parle d'organes
[Applaudissements]
je regarde la sueur de l'entreprise
c'est trop chaud
m
alors maintenant michèle bernier avait
l'air drôle c'est d'ailleurs ça m'a
manqué moi c'est un jour on allait
chercher un peu de faire un peu de
promotion serre ges que je perds mon
jingle promotion s'il vous plaît
voilà allez top bien alors vous a voulu
jouer dans un film
oui absolument je la fais ça tu as
douanes ou le titre d'un film de camille
de casabianca qui s'appelle vive nous
oui 1 avec manuel avec camille de
casablanca avec daniel prévost avec
thibault de montalembert des données
dieudonné à l'extraordinaire dieudonné
fait pour le judo est formidable c'est
un bon acteur de nommer un
extraordinaire comme en politique il est
un peu chiant des fois mais comme acteur
il est arrivé surtout chiant quand on
est de droite info bien vous nous
raconter l'histoire
et bien c'est je dirais c'est une
chronique sur le bilan amoureux de trois
femmes tout à fait différentes les unes
des autres
moi je suis un peu celle qui est cherche
à tout prix
le prince charmant accent cheval et
y'a qu'à mickaël plus tôt et se retrouve
dans les désastres de la séparation
et puis emmanuelle devos qui elle est
une femme extrêmement arriviste et
carriériste et qui elle couche pour y
arriver voilà tout ce que moi daniel
bravo que je suis utile ils prévoient
d'ailleurs donc ans a comme on fait la
liste de vos amants avec vos copines en
fait c'est l'histoire de trois copines
un saignement et puis à un moment vous
laisser vous de moi j'en ai 62 dans le
film je précise vous laissez votre liste
l'oublier oui je la jette dans la
poubelle la vie voilà puis le mari l'a
trop il marie l'a trouvé en pensant que
c'est sa femme qui a eu cette liste
damman hallucinante avant lui et donc ça
se passe pas très bien entendu quoi bon
lui et pas trop grand chose à dire
puisqu'il a une maîtresse son côté des
nombreux pubs pour lui dire qu'il a
acquis le voilà en disant bien
puisqu'elle a déjà mangé profité pour
partir jeu comme ça je serais pas
coupable et puis voilà quoi bien orane
est donc
le personnage que vous jouez en fait dès
qu'un mec vous invite à déjeuner vous
pensez que tout de suite
or en samarie enfants pavillon jogging
bière de football tablier à pois télé
tout voilà c'est ça la vie de tous les
jours ses rêves total
voilà je dois rêver tous les jours ça ça
vous arrive certains maîtres malgras
perçu et je pense à dézoner vous
annoncez ont fait flipper oui pense que
lui pense à moi femme au foyer oui enfin
vous voyez mais s'il fait des projets
sap r j'ai avec moi à long terme s'ils
pensent à ça que pour moi ça me déçoit
un petit peu non je préfère qu'ils
pensent à moi pour le ludique la choix
plutôt que les fonds non c'est isabelle
vive nous donc ça sort ça sent le 26 je
vais me voilà on va regarder un petit
extrait du film serge magnéto jeanne
alpinistes cet architecte annoncé trop
cet archipel ya gérard un médecin du
samu
c'est rassurant un médecin parlant celui
là il était héroïnomane et wajir lépi
culteurs fêtera le top quoi que c'est
bouillot jean bouilhou ouais ouais je
sais c'est fait ou paris sans four
[Applaudissements]
voilà
ses démêlés avec dieudonné camille de
casablanca daniel prévost emmanuelle
devos et thibault de montalembert un
casting un petit peu original je trouve
que c'était bien de la part de camille
de réunir tous ces gens là oui c'est un
film très très forts car il sait ce
qu'elle fait pékin deux centrales vous
connaissez pékin central gerard d'arvor
oui avec lille rennes et dans le rôle de
poivre d'arvor
c'est vrai il régnait qui joue le rôle
de patrick poivre d'arvor qui joue un
grand reporter très bien parce qu'elle
plus drôle dans le film je le dis
maintenant parce que la prescription
c'est très très longtemps
pékin central d'un film est de 85 par
ebay avec ses chaussettes
il est chaud cette offre il ya quelqu'un
d'autre est précisé que bien alors vous
regardez l'émission puisque vous la
regardez pour l'ina vous nous l'avez dit
tout à l'heure vous savez quand il ya un
jingle il faut pas bouger
non je ne la regarde pas pour linda je
ne regarde que linda est d'accord c'est
une nuance
vous savez moi
voilà vous savez bien que tentant jingle
c'est comme ça il faut pas bouger
ça y est un crack ah non alors megève et
sans regarder la ccra quant à vous
demander de faire la prochaine fois
prenez mireille mathieu directement et
que vous avez tous bouger quand même
c'est vrai il forcément bon prenez pas
de jamais là pour faire un truc ça
marchera pas c'est lui qui disait jamais
de gesticuler sans arrêt vous êtes prête
oui quoique en bas oui c'est une
interview si j'étais d'accord si vous
étiez pamela anderson
ben je rampais embêté parce qu'alors son
mari me plaît pas du tout du tout du
tout alors le côté tu que ton nom alors
vraiment pas ne vous est il arrivé une
tonne et ben je ferais pareil kel away
ah ouais je chercherai devenir maîtres
du monde à la place de mon mari et puis
après je le fous dehors
oui d'accord parce que je sans toi ah
ouais moi je trouve qu'elle est très
très bien se situer ophélie winter
ah bah il ya longtemps que j'aurai des
valises et tous les magasins que je
serai serait tellement content d'être
ophélie winter ça vous plairait d'être
au fait des winter a physiquement oui ça
qu'au fur et à mesure qu'on vous dit
dénoncé pas s'ils ont été quinze ans un
certain ordre vous y croyez de plus en
plus vous n'êtes pas ophélie winter
mais je crois que j'aurais fait
autrement pour prendre du recul avec mon
mec que d'aller ramer six mois céline
dion céline dion aubin sera resté moche
parce que avec la voix qu'elle a je veux
dire elle pouvait dire merde à tout le
monde politique est claire chazal
moi je suis embêté parce que je sais pas
si je ferai rires ouais si vous étiez
d'une barbie alors là par contre je
m'habillerais avec un sac poubelle je
mettrai des boutons tout ça des cheveux
gras et pour arrêter de faire de l'ombre
à michèle bernier on peut relever
pour revenir sur hillary clinton hillary
clinton veut se lancer dans la politique
elle aussi pourquoi pas ce qu'elle a
envie de baiser elle aussi va faire
maintenant l'invité mystère donc je vais
poser des questions à l'invité mystère g
famille interview vous allez écouter
même si vous le reconnaissez avant la
fin de l'interview vous ne dites pas qui
c'est mais c'est seulement à la fin de
l'interview que je vous demanderais qui
sait est-ce que l'invité mystère
m'entends c'est une histoire vous
entends bien donc je dirais pour aider
nos amis que vous c'est le fils de dark
vador
alors c'est bien jean d'ormesson non ses
prêches gendarmes qui nous attend vous
vous êtes chanteur au début des années
70 vous avez chanté dans les maisons des
jeunes et de la culture avec vos deux
frères sous le nom de bibi funk n'est ce
pas oui vous chantiez quoi le chausson
quel genre de chansons invité mystère
libyenne
les robes très bien vous êtes écrivain
oui en 1987 vous avez écrit un essai de
philosophie politique intitulé hadjadj
aura non h doha pardon excusez moi mais
dès que c'est des noms étrangers j'ai du
mal
donc vous êtes j'ai dit chanteur homme
poli enfin écrivain vous êtes un homme
politique en 1992 et milité pour le non
à maastricht
d'autant que politique oui j'ai pris des
positions politiques en tant que citoyen
tout simplement
donc vous n'êtes pas un politique
certainement moins ça nous éclaire vous
êtes comédiens oui en 1996 étiez sur
scène vous juillet une pièce qui
s'appelait l'affrontement et la pièce
était assez bien nommé puisque quand
vous étiez sur scène il ya un huissier
qui est monté pour récupérer des bêtes
que que vous devez
et vous l'avez boxer sur ce sont
représentation huissier c'est pas mal
c'était un film gay d'un film que vous
aviez produits c'est un film que vous
aviez produit vous aviez perdu de
l'argent ce qui prouve que vous êtes
aussi producteur de cinéma vous avez été
en tous les cas vous êtes éditeur vous
dirigez une collection dans une maison
d'édition qui s'appelle les belles
lettres
une collection qui s'appelle
architecture du verbe qui traite de
l'évolution des formes poétiques travail
siècle donc vous avez vous avez une idée
déjà fait vous êtes industrielle en 1987
vous avez racheté une société de
fabrication de jouets et vous l'avez
redresser en quelques mois
non deux ans et demi je m'attends
demander à nos amis il ya une dernière
question peut-être qu'il vous est posée
juste parce que pour nous mettre
vraiment sur la peau est ce que vous
êtes beau football
oui oui on coule donc oui vous avez
deviné ce qui nombre des les deux frères
j'ai deviné
ah oui l'affrontement quand même ouais
c'est donc joe dalton moi c'est sur
l'histoire de lusine parce que deux ans
et demi je vois bien en effet il à
redresser cette entreprise moi je vois
aussi qui s'est fait par bernard tapie
alors qu'en général lui le voilà c'est
j'ai hésité jusqu'à ce moment là et ces
deux ans et demi qui m'a fait comprendre
qu'ils savaient de les revendre
il faut tenter une réponse collective
c'est ce moment que tu montes dix neuf
noms d'attention un deux trois phrases
ça c'était les deux frères il est bien
votre truc c'est en tout cas ça commence
à la france et ça ça va bien mais tu
sais que ton truc de l'invité mystère
rtt derrière tu es tout seul c'est
flippant
vous allez garder vos lunettes pendant
toute la soirée non non non je vais les
enlever mais le problème c'est que j'ai
un vrai problème la deux quand il ya
trop de lumière brille en ce moment
j'étais plus problème avec les yeux mais
je peux les enlever si tu dis c'est
vraiment des lunettes de soudeur la cdci
de devinettes pour protéger deux
vainqueurs d'hier et celle de la longue
pour l'équipe mais quand tu te rappelles
tu te rappelles quand même tu avais fait
une émission qui s'appelait lunettes
noires lunettes noires pour nuits grand
chose qui va me reprocher si tu savais
ya une question que j'aurais pu vous
posez francis lalanne mais je mets déjà
tellement posée donc on va la voir sur
le petit magnéto magnéto serge et
raconter je choque souvent à l'eau non
mais là c'était beaucoup plus choquant
mais jean pierre graff noter que quand
tu étais sur celle que tu chanter devant
un public comme ça tu es tu étais
tellement bien que tu joue ici dans ton
slip
j'ai lu dans une interview que des fois
sur scène ça dure est tellement
longtemps tu étais tellement bien que tu
avais des éjaculations sur scène c'est
vrai ça ou c'est la journaliste qui
avait inventé ça on ça m'est arrivé ça
m'arrivait mais j'étais vraiment bien ce
jour là il faut croire j'espère ça va
t'arriver aujourd'hui
c'était ma première année de télévision
[Applaudissements]
ah bah oui celui qui jouissait là
manifestement c'était bonnard marquise
était plus agréable de vous voir sans
lunettes
si c'est une dame qui me le dôme la part
d'andré de ligne c'est vrai que j'ai pas
j'ai pas toujours été tendre avec vous
je me souviens d'une fois dans hardy
matt va pouvez pas vous en souvenir vous
étiez pas remarqué sans doute m'a
regardé je regarde pas la magnéto serge
et maintenant on applaudit fond si cela
[Applaudissements]
aussi
6 g bonsoir francis comment se passe
cette tournée à travers la france elle
se passe bien cette tournée en suisse
oui se passe bien pitoyable et c'est
pitoyable
mais j'avais un mec avec une coque qui
tirait la tête d'allaoui c'était c'était
surtout de ce qu'on a fait à cet animal
qui m'a qui m'a dérangé mais c'est fini
il ya prescription scherrer a banni
remis et puis des cultures avec brigitte
bardot
on avait fait ça avec sophie favier la
vie de pintade et qui avait un collier
je lui parlais que c'est vraiment
sérieux pour la pâte
vous faites don quichotte en mars au
théâtre de boulogne billancourt y jouer
le rôle de
dix truites avec alexandre aubry dans le
rôle de sancho pança une pléiade de
jeunes acteurs prodigieux spécialiste du
travail avec les masques etc
une mise en scène de françois bourcier
francis lalanne ya aussi un cd qui sort
qui s'appelle sans papiers oui en fait
c'est un peu pour ça que j'étais non
master merci de le montrer voilà c'est
ça fait sept ans j'arrête un nom mais en
jarez seulement lors gérer démontre le
single single c'est pour la promo se
demande si on va l'écouter derrière le
single
écoutez
dans le ciel
m
[Applaudissements]
alors pdg
tout jeu
en payant sur ce plateau quel sens du
dialogue plutôt bien géré cette
rencontre allait soudain bouleverser le
destin de cette loi ne semblait
prédestiner à se rencontrer me demande
de vous arrêter
d'accord vous l'avez sorti le 1er
janvier aux jours fériés vous dites
c'est que 100 dinars ce que vous
déclarez sujet va vous dites c'est
continuer le sortir le 10 le 1er janvier
c'est continuer à rester dans mon espace
hors du temps comme je vais toujours été
je sors un jour on ne peut pas l'acheter
oui un disque qui vient de nulle part
c'est normal je sors un jour on ne peut
pas l'acheter indices qui gène de la
nouvelle maison qui doit être content de
moi je trouve que c'est une bonne
démarche
non non tout cas moi je trouve qu'il a
eu raison bon c'est vrai qu'il ya eu des
soucis apparemment le procès de ça mais
il a eu raison d'attendre parce que
c'est bien un petit peu qu'on ait oublié
le lalanne chanteur pour qu'ils
reviennent avec un disque j'ai eu un
excellent papier sur l'album dans
l'événement du jeudi de cette semaine et
il aidé moi même le premier surpris
parce que il ya non encore on n'avait
pas eu un bon papier sur francis taulan
dans l'événement du jeudi dont il ne
l'est pas ça
je plaisais pas conditionnel donc
des passages à bien ce qu'ils faisaient
aujourd'hui on reviendra et pourquoi
vous n'avez pas choisi le 29 février
on n'aurait pas eu besoin d'en parler
aujourd'hui à 6 la dame sans papiers
donc le nouveau cd et les duels le
nouveau single vous reste avec nous et
bien avec grand plaisir et dans les
trophées du ridicule
bon d'accord stéphane bern est arrivé à
la bunny
[Applaudissements]
l'émission a caché un lycéen à bah oui
parce que il compte sur france 2 depuis
huit jours stéphanie avait vu chez ma
copine christine bravo messieurs
frontière et ont nourri bien je trouve
vous êtes si bien qu'ils sont
responsables ils vous donnent des
boutons à ce poids là carole rousseau
home non ça y est tout de suite il faut
qu'ils balancent mais non quand je les
aime tellement mais c'était la période
de trêve des confiseurs je donne un
premier trophée du ridicule à stéphane
bern par alex north franchement vous
avez alexandra broeckaert ce à côté de
lui qui mettrait qu on est tous d'accord
d'accord il a tout fait pour plus
d'avoir fait tomber sur pire aujourd'hui
au nom alors ça je le sais mais c'est
ton avis leur en coûte elle et je vote
tant de trophées du ridicule
il n'y a pas eu beau dominer gariel sont
pas des élections assis au nom bien
alors donc pas non à faire les trophées
du ridicule donc le jury c'est stéphane
bern c'est gérard miller c'est laurent
ruquier c'est isabelle alonso vous vous
êtes auditeurs libres pouvez vous
exprimer
et rendez vous ne vous ferez ce
consultant vous ne votez pas ap
or sa septième saison
la tête
[Musique]
bien alors première catégorie donc
chanson la première nomination va à
céline dion et rené angelil en 99 ils
ont tenu une conférence de presse à
paris pour annoncer que la femme céline
allait se remarier avec son mari et le
mari rené allait se remarier avec sa
femme c'est ainsi que 5 janvier dernier
rené s'afficher dans une jolie panoplie
de demis roussos et céline dans celle
d'une pseudo cléopâtre images d'avant de
succès bon ce formidable show business
la vie de limousines et d'hôtels et ça
c'est formidable mais de conduire ma
propre voiture et de choisir mes propres
tomates d'aller au marché puis de faire
la cuisine puis de créer autrement c'est
ce que j ravi pour l'instant vous
sachiez que tout égard et on touche du
bois
merci le bon dieu bon évidemment je suis
sur scène chante y trouve que je suis la
plus belle fille la meilleure chanteuse
du monde ça me fait super plaisir
mais ce qui me fait vraiment plaisir
c'est qu'ils me disent qu'il a besoin de
moi et ça s'est il pas plus beaux quais
douceur pour une fin je pars pas de
chanteuse
je vais vous donner un petit scoop le 5
rebonds 5 c cnet chiffre chanceux et ça
fait cinq ans que ça va faire cinq ans
que rené et moi on est mariés déjà et le
5 janvier ont régné mon se remarie à las
vegas avec les amis les copains pour
cinquième anniversaire de mariage
[Applaudissements]
chansons
premiers nominés céline dion et rené
angelil le deux prochains tourtereaux
prétendants au titre se sont lara fabian
et patrick fiori
contrairement à certains ils n'ont pas
de soucis de vie privée puisque ils
s'embrassent aussi souvent que possible
en public y compris à la télévision mais
où l'on frise le ridicule c'est quand
lara multiplie les déclarations
politiques du genre l'amour c'est comme
une chanson en six à huit après 10
secondes c'est un peu rapide ça 10
secondes pour un garçon d'origine corse
non
j'attends
[Applaudissements]
chacun
j'attends
je
[Applaudissements]
alors notez le daily mail on s'est serré
la série alors toujours dans la
catégorie chanson pour terminer un film
winter il ya un an et demi elle sortait
un album intitulé privé si il y a
quelques semaines elle sortait un nouvel
album intitulé privé si la différence
entre les deux albums aucune la pochette
et fait même à l'intérieur n'a tout de
même droit à quelques nouvelles chansons
la première version s'est modestement
vendu à 180 milles exemplaires
elle espère avec la nouvelle satisfaire
aux objectifs de sa maison de disques
c'est bien vu mais c'est un peu ridicule
quand même qu'ils testaient nouveau dans
à part évidemment que c'est une nouvelle
chanson mais vous avez travaillé avec
une nouvelle équipe avec de nouveaux
musiciens dans nos studios ce qu'on sait
que vous aimez bien comme ça aller
chercher
ouais de nouvelles têtes guy novès dit
débat en fait ça c'est un titre s'était
normalement le premier titre de privacy
et je les fais avec quelqu'un qui est
devenu chanteur par la suite avant les
producteurs
donc j'ai eu un peu de mal à récupérer
le titre pour le mettre sur l'album donc
on la met de côté et donc je les
ressentais le lotois n'ont eu la chance
d'en chercher le titre
et non il me plaisait pas spécialement
envie de manger
non mais bon bref c'est pas le vrai fait
quoi et tout de suite non quoi tout de
suite à quoi la réenregistrer remixé et
puis voilà ça fait partie maintenant de
la nouvelle impression de sessa donc
l'album est hélas il s'appelle privacy
il existe depuis un an fin il m'a vue
est bonne et il va y avoir une nouvelle
une réédition de cet album
[Applaudissements]
après céline dion et rené angelil et
l'invs a bien arrêté pour filtrer palmer
la palme du ridicule
oui le trophée du ridicule céline dion
et rené oui c'est l'une des causes du
bébé congelé vous savez ils ont bien peu
de sperme dans le dans le congélateur au
cas où ils pouvaient plus faire
d'enfants mais maintenant ils vont
sortir ont réchauffé tout ça sur la
banquise ça va être formidable ans
effectivement pour vous c'est céline
dion pour vous j'ai remis leur en paraît
moins de dix noms d'abord je trouve
absolument pas ridicule céline dion et
rené c'est l'accent canadien
ils sont canadiens je trouve beauty
fitou et on n'arrive jamais à trouver
quelque chose de différent du trop de
rigueur décès et l'année l'accent
canadien en mai dès que ces dix ans
canadien fabian et fury joie parce qu'il
ya eu de ridicule de s'embrasser 10
secondes ça me semble beaucoup pour un
certain nombre de gens que je connais
donc je vais plutôt me rabattre sur
fellini winter je ne sais pas très bien
pourquoi mais j'ai le sentiment que
c'est comme à la grande époque vous
savez qu'on disait à l'époque là s'il ne
savait pas pourquoi en vouloir aux
américains ça ne fait rien dites-leur
quand même que c'est leur faute eux
savent pourquoi mais donc je vais
choisir ophélie winter
mais ce qui me gêne un peu c'est je ne
savais pas que dans la disposition du
plateau je serai en face de stéphane
bern pourquoi est ce que c'est un peu la
charité qui se moque de l'hôpital sur le
ridicule
j'ai l'impression d'être en face d'un
miroir et me dire je suis aussi ridicule
que ce cch honneur décerné comme
ridicule soit en effet stéphane mais
c'est pas ça c'est que comme le plus
personne sur ton dit vente est obligé de
venir s'asseoir sur les
ce n'est pas tout la mesure mais la
baisse a fortement accéléré des procès
c'est ridicule on devait déjà s'auto
accordée à un trophée du ridicule parce
que c'est vraiment ridicule d'un trophée
du moniteur donc moi je leur donne un
délai bon alors autorisé mérité selon
vous ce qui alors moi sans hésitation
franchement lara fabian et patrick suet
parce que les séries voilà ce que
j'apprécie qui s'embrassent souvent la
télévision parce que pendant ce temps là
il chante pas plus belle c'est trash et
c'est moi qui départage bah oui oui mais
en fait on parle de ridicule on n'a pas
besoin de se mêler des histoires
d'enfants congelés tout ça mais céline
dion et rené le mariage avant égyptien
et qu'ils ont fait à las vegas alors là
bas prix dictus alors que les cubains la
célèbre régate pour épouser un vieux
jetons ça me paraît normal je m'offrirai
bien je prendrais bien la place de ces
dames je m'offrirai bien l'environnement
lauréat en lauréat quoi way
j'aimerais bien te lauréats j'aimerais
je préfèrerais que vous l'avez déjà vu
le trophée du ridicule à 92 4
dit pourquoi je suis pas candidat au
trophée des trophées du ridicule
oh la la
pas celles habilitées
je suis très déçu ne l'aiment pas
chercher leur trophée en costume c'est
dégueulasse aux césars ils viennent une
fois remerciements maintenant on
continue avec la catégorie donc
politique politique est ridicule font
souvent bon ménage
vous allez vous en apercevoir avec cette
nouvelle salve de nominations et là on
commence avec xavier artibat la femme du
maire de paris je cite mon mari est un
saint ouais pour pas être discourtois on
va juste émettre l'hypothèse que xavière
tiberi a relu charles péguy qui disait
j'aime bien 5 et des défauts qu'un
pêcheur qui n'en a pas on est un couple
uni
j'ai défendre et il change jusqu'au bout
salut mon mari vous paraître ridicule
c'est un innocent c'est un saint il sera
sûrement un jour béatifié s'est redit
que ce que je vais dire bien sûr ça vous
paraît ridicule
jamais un centime jamais le conseil
d'état n'a trouvé un centime s'ils
avaient voulu s'avère utile
nous pourrions voir des maisons de
campagne pourrait y avoir des
appartements voilà xavière tiberi non
cette image est génial on proposait
l'émission nos amours là de jean luc
reichmann quand elle interroge la femme
et qui alary en médaillon à côté mais
qu'on vérifie leur réponse après c'était
tout à fait ça c'est cela mon mari est à
ça on savait qu'ils étaient sacrés qu'on
met consacré fallait pas exagérer mais
l'a dit elle-même vous avez trouvé ça
ridicule
ouais donc elle se dénonce un petit peu
notre deuxième candidat ridicule c'est
dominique strauss kahn
si le ministre des finances a
démissionné immédiatement après avoir
été mis en cause dans l' affaire de la
mnef
c'est sans doute parce qu'il savait
qu'il avait commis un certain nombre de
bourdes
il a tout d'abord versé au dossier une
lettre qui a été établie par la justice
comme étant un faux mais le problème
c'est qu'il a aussi fourni une autre
lettre censé être une réponse à ce faux
une lettre écrite sur du papier de la
mnef dans l'en-tête n'existait pas à
l'époque
bref strauss a fini par valls m si je
démissionne je le dis avec force ce
n'est en aucune manière parce que je me
sens coupable comme citoyen je souhaite
maintenant pouvoir m'expliquer
rapidement devant la justice aussi bien
sur la réalité de mon travail sur le
montant de mes honoraires que sur les
irrégularités de
arm qui ont pu être commises enfin comme
en ce moment douloureux je veux dire
aussi à mon épouse à ma famille à mes
amis à quel point leur soutien mais
précieux après que xavière tiberi donc
cette histoire nous connaissez
l'histoire donc il fait une fausse
facture et sur cette facture ils
oublient qu'à l'époque il y avait déjà
le 0 1 devant les numéros de téléphone
parce que même luc besson dans jeanne
d'arc il n'a pas fait ces erreurs là
c'est quelque chose à dire non mais
c'est le truc à dire mais j'ai peur de
t'ennuyer parle à quelqu'un qui ment pas
c'est bien toi alors
landi moi sincèrement je sais quand il
est parti j'étais vraiment embêté quoi
passer on a tous fait on avait tous
cotisés pour lui alors faire quelque
chose et c'est la boulette
le problème c'est qu'on en sait rien sur
un an reste en attendant n'en sais rien
je rêve je rappelle qu'en france tant
que quelqu'un n'a pas été condamné il
est réputé innocent alors la présomption
d'innocence et restaurer sa troupe alors
tu les fais le coup et ça pue et quand
ça tombe ça tourne ça tourne pas je
plaisante bien
alors donc on a vu une bonne année
invité gérard miller pour être chiant
comme ça sur blessure
xavière tiberi on a vu le hic strauss
kahn et pour finir dominique vous allez
le pourrait d'ailleurs recevoir
plusieurs nominations une pour avoir
déclaré qu'elle n'était pas certaine que
la marée noire soit une catastrophe
écologique
ensuite comme la marée noire l'a quand
même dérangé lors de ses vacances à la
réunion
elle avait soulevé la question suivante
les pêcheurs blanc de l'île d'yeu
mérite-il plus d'attention que les
pêcheurs un peu bronzé d enter remarqué
avec le goudron des plages et les plumes
des oiseaux mazoutés
les pêcheurs auraient pu lui
confectionner un joli costume c'est
quand même un peu ce que le mérite de
grande ampleur mais ce n'est pas comme
certains me précédait le derrière le
porte-drapeau des pères accable ce matin
dominique voynet dans une interview au
parisien elle a eu une réaction
d'infirmières dans une situation de
catastrophe dit il elle a donc commis
une erreur profonde voilà
un récidiver
on a vu par exemple cette semaine
qu'elle a fait une déclaration à propos
des militaires sur le 14 juillet en
disant qu'elle avait assisté au défilé
militaire pour voir que de près que les
militaires étaient vraiment des cons
ouais et lorsqu'il n'a pas envie d'être
ministre qu on la vire parce qu'on n'a
pas besoin d'elle c'est parce qu'il faut
pas oublier que qui est en train de
ramasser qui est d'entrain je suis pas
mis tarif qui est en train de ramasser
le mazout s'est quand même l'armée
française et qui est-ce qui va au kosovo
faire la paix
c'est l'armée alors s'il ya bien une
femme qui depuis des années se bat pour
l'écologie c'est quand même pas de sa
faute si un pétrolier qui se pète la
gueule en pleine entraîneur c'est plutôt
de les aider faute d'ajustement dd2 jean
louis debré dé philippe de villiers et
autres qui prêche pour les grands
patrons le libéralisme et tout ça c'est
eux c'est à cause d'eux que c'est la
recherche du profit qu'il ya ce genre
d'accident c'est pas à cause de voiliers
devraient voter collomb vous depuis
quelques années jamais alors gueuler pas
contre la seule qui ait la haine nous
défendre sur ce sujet de ses amis
apple va te dire
htc ger la faute et économie à mon tour
et dit non mais la défense de m
alors les terres sont des camps je vous
le confirme
j'ai écouté j'ai vu deux des fils et moi
aussi j'étais au défilé militaire du 14
juillet
j'étais sur les champs-elysées j'ai vu
le défilé militaire du 14-juillet coûté
hier des militaires qui défilait à
cheval à part en cas d'invasion de la
camargue
expliquez-moi quoi ça peut servir
j'ai bien noté que c'était une émission
drôle donc laurent et moi ce soir on est
à côté de la plaque complètement de
l'émission aujourd'hui on est ennuyeux
bon alors maintenant sérieusement vous
allez voter non non donc dsk l'a d'abord
voynet je trouve que c'est fort de café
en effet de s'en prendre à une des rares
personnes
même s'il a fait une boulette de
communication incontestable une des
rares personnes qui se bat plutôt du
côté des écologistes pour qui moi je ne
vote pas personnellement mais il faut le
reconnaître
quant à madame tibéri là en effet c'est
pas seulement parce qu'elle est droite
parce que il faut quand même savoir ce
que c'est que la béatification elle
évoque en disant avec le plus grand
sérieux que son mari un jour pour
devenir saint je crois que si ça c'est
pas le ridicule alors que vous êtes se
sont impliqués
est-ce que je ne suis pas rançon aux
catholiques qu'ils sont se dit que quand
on sait la lenteur avec laquelle
l'église des sites que quelqu'un il sen
le dire pour eux son mari d'ailleurs
c'est quand même un petit peu bien
stéphane bern venait moi je trouve ça
charmant une femme qui fait une faire
une déclaration d'amour
mon mari est un saint ça veut dire qui
de la touche pas et c'est formidable
les faits moi je suis pas écolo mais
juillet quand même conseiller municipal
à paris isabelle alors moi c'est moi je
trouve que strauss kahn il est plutôt il
s'est comporté plutôt dignement que voix
n'est effectivement lui fait un faux
procès puisque n'étant de ridicule elle
est vraiment imbattable madame tibéri la
lame et sillery ça fait deux
curieusement je vote pour strauss kahn
attention papa qu'il a démissionné
effectivement c'est très bien mais pour
la connerie d'abord qu'il a fait à cause
de lui on l'a perdue anne sinclair à la
télévision métal maintenant lui là il a
plus de boulot non plus un couple de
chômeurs à qui n'avait pas les mains de
chômeurs de francis lalanne la chanson
est là et pas celle là je vais pas sa
colère c'est terrible pour la chanter
ouais bon petit bout
j'ai comme des mains de laboureurs qui
peut plus glamour et j'ai comme des
mains du chirurgien m'avait attendons
franchement c'est cox est bien pauvre à
des inconnus on l'a oublié la pauvre
anne à cause de dominique strauss-kahn
et que dans les cocktails et objet de
rappeler aux gens qu'ils cessent
souvenez vous c'est que vous regardiez
chaque dimanche soir à 19h les gens font
bonjour maggie alors dont le net
dans la catégorie politique
non
templeuve rome
véhicule mais enfin ça la catégorie
cinéma
la première nomination ça ne surprendra
personne va à sophie marceau pour son
ridicule monologue lors de la cérémonie
de clôture du dernier festival de cannes
sophie confie qu'il ya beaucoup à dire
sur ce qu'ils récitent des textes nul
comme des cons c'est d'ailleurs un petit
peu ce que je suis en train de faire en
ce moment certains morceaux
il s'agissait en fait d'un pétage de
plombs et d'autre chose que du cinéma
parce qu'il ya d'autres choses
importantes dans le cinéma et puis et
puis j'ai passé une journée avec des
enfants gravement malades et je peux
vous dire c'est le cinéma est une chose
qui compte dans le monde plutôt que de
faire la guerre on fait du cinéma et je
vous dis que ça fait rêver les gens et
ça leur donne un but un projet à court
terme est quelque chose qui reste pour
toujours
ceux du marché elle va être dur à battre
quand on a mal sincèrement je trouve
cette intervention les plus émouvantes
que j'ai entendu au festival on a déjà
vu un petit accès de jalousie un jeu
comme ça je la connais absolument pas
mais si j'ai bien compris cette histoire
elle avait vu en effet des enfants dans
des situations dramatiques et elle
témoignait d'une façon en barbouillé ya
pas de doute de son émotion quand on
s'appelle mars au fait du mime dans ce
cas la médiation entre auteurs et
interprètes c'est là qu'on a vu sourire
donc quelle catégorie cinéma on a
commencé avec sophie marceau on continue
avec alain delon
comment s'est-il rendu ridicule tout
simplement en interdisant une biographie
de lui même alors qu'elle n'était même
pas écrite selon les termes exacts de la
plainte de l'acteur cette biographie ne
constituent en réalité qu'une collection
de calomnies délégation gravement
diffamatoires et d'atteinte
particulièrement pernicieuse à
l'intimité de sa vie privée fin de
citation rappelons enfin que l'auteur de
cette bio répond au doux nom de violet
qui du coup se retrouver marc on savait
que celui qui
notre confrère qui voulait écrire une
biographie sur vous et que vous avez
fait interdire écoutez usage un jugement
sur le fond nous être prononcée le 14
octobre je m'étais donné comme règle de
ne pas en parler mais puisque nous
sommes tant sur les chaînes
confidentielles et compte tenu de
l'heure tardive je vais vous en dire
deux mots si vous le permettez je n'ai
rien n'interdit je n'ai pas interdit un
livre contrairement à ce qu'on dit
j'allais atterrir 3g venir
non j'ai interdit certains passages d'un
synopsis qui était profondément
injurieuses et calomnieux
ce qui d'ailleurs été reconnue par le
tribunal comme calomnieux injurieux
mondial avant même qu'elle soit écrit
sur simple vue d'un synopsis
vous trouvez ça franchement puisqu'on
n'a pas le choix du terme donc on va
dire ridicule mais vrai que c'est quand
même une athlète absolument flagrante à
la liberté d'expression pas la même
sensibilité parce que je trouve que dans
les extraits il y avait notamment une
atteinte profonde à romy schneider et
sur des histoires très personnelle entre
et romy schneider et alain doulé dire
que moi je ne viendrai pas vraiment été
nommé pas sale je défend alain delon
parce que je trouve qu'ils adorent
chacun a droit justement à sa vie privée
je suis désarmée juillet pour une fois
plutôt d'accord avec stéphane bern
parce que franchement n'importe qui à la
place d'alain delon aurait réagi de la
même façon vous savez qui est un bouquin
qui va sortir sur vous on raconte les
pires dégueulasserie sur vous même si
vous les avez fait vous faites tout ce
qu'il faut pour qu'une tient certes pas
dit que vous soyez un sens c'est plus
quelque part
mais qui se dit tiens je vais faire un
bouquin dégueulasse un ballon et s'est
dit je sais que je vais ramasser de la
thune obligatoirement troisième candidat
au titre le réalisateur patrice leconte
il avait déjà commis un film
prémonitoire ridicule en 96 ans 99 la
prémonition s'est révélé exact
comment ben en envoyant un fax ou il se
plaignait de la férocité de la critique
seulement au chu de renvoyer le fax à
l'erp est une association d'auteurs et
de réalisateurs et de l'envoyer à la
haye afp l'agencé france presse qui ne
s'est pas gratter pour arroser toutes
les rédactions résultat des courses au
moment même où il sortait un livre on a
pu lire des trucs du genre ce que l'on
préfère dans l'île et patrice leconte
c'est son titre chez un imposteur le
ridicule du cinéaste et attire donc la
scélératesse du journaliste est ce que
parce que c'est vrai que cette lettre
était prévu pour être envoyés à la rp et
qu'elle a été envoyé par ailleurs la lfp
oui enfin c'est ça c'est vraiment
l'allumette par dessus l'épaule ça c'est
clair
c'est vrai que cette lettre était
destinée sa part mes confrères parce que
j'avais envie qu'on se réunisse on se
connaît pas tous loin s'en faut
pour évoquer sa pour que ma carrière ne
reste pas une colère silencieuse et
enfin solitaire en tout cas ouais et il
se trouve que il ya eu un maire d'âge
dans le fac de rp que ses participations
ffp
alors vous dirais que je me cite dans
mes propres émissions
il s'en passe des choses chez eux que
chez vous il se défend bien et gardiner
justement nous arrivons au terme de
cette présentation nouveauté pour qui
stéphane sans conteste pour ce film
arceaux une grande impression le sort du
le joueur du festival de cannes est les
jeux j'aime beaucoup les enfants et je
vais aussi voilà mais je suis pas obligé
d'aller raconter quand il s'agit du
cinéma rialto viennent parler des rois
je parle des rois quand on parle des
enfants je parle des gens très bien donc
sophie marceau pour bouger hormis leur
pas d'hésitation certainement pas sophie
marceau certainement pas patrice leconte
et donc par élimination et pour les
raisons sus évoqué alain delon l'un
d'eux l'ont alors non non non moi je
défends delonge défend aussi patrice
leconte que je trouve un réalisateur
formidable chauffe-piscine tellement
courageux je trouve de de s'en prendre
aux critiques parce qu'on sait qu'on va
en recevoir plein la gueule en échange
des cons fait ça s'est passé ces
kamikazes donc c'est tellement
réellement courageux a fait ça alors
bravo à lui
et alors là il me reste sophie marceau
puis comme festival de cannes je trouve
que vraiment c est là la palme isabelle
de long et le conte sont dans la même
catégorie c'est à dire des gens qui sont
trop pour s'intéresser à ce qu'on dit
d'eux dans les basses air voilà donc
c'est pas du ridicule c'est une erreur
je crois et sophie marceau elle est très
sympathiquement ridicule dans ce passage
parce que je trouve qu'elle pète un peu
les plombs dans une assemblée qui est
déjà par elle-même un parangon de
ridicule c'était ridicule au carré c'est
vraiment sympa je vote sans hésiter pour
sophie marceau
[Applaudissements]
catégorie cinéma
le faire
c'est bizarre tout cas le trophée du
ridicule
je ne comprends rien vous arriver
qu'est ce qui va nous arriver parce que
vous arrivez processeur c'est une
punition wii qui est infligé à certains
auraient lithiques par le sepa
corporelle si vous êtes mosaïque et oui
et vous allez avoir une m'ouvrit ni
achats d'or je peux chanter deux
chansons corses
allons-y vous êtes modalités parents
population balade accord est pas du
patrick fiori ou ce boulot simon
les
hé hé millenia
nana
haget
m
riesch
non
on continue le boulot à fait d'accord
c'est pas il pose des bombes sur la
glace tu veux
bien passons maintenant à alain
cantillon une société avec les trois
personnalités qui postule au trophée du
plus ridicule de l'aneth
pour commencer voici l'homme qui est
persuadé est venu de la planète
altaïr pour fonder l'atlantide paco
rabanne que le couturier s'invente des
vies antérieures soit mais là où
simplement lancé la chute de la station
orbitale mir sur paris pour le 11 août
dernier la destruction de la capitale et
allez savoir pourquoi celle du gers
l'été a donc failli être moche mais
harry brûlera et ça sera pendant d'une
journée obscures
oui d'ailleurs écrit l'équipe soleil et
là j'ai eu un flash et vu cette bombe
voilà voilà enfin caravane on se demande
jean qui lui ouvre son antenne pour des
conneries leur catégorie parce qu'ils
sont durs pour les autres qui sont en
concurrence mais on va se suivant même
dans le ridicule l'union fait la force
c'est ce que nous ont prouvé en février
99 les trois hommes qui sont restés
coincés pendant dix jours à 3000 m
d'altitude dans le massif de la vanoise
retrouver après les efforts d'une
centaine de personnes les trois rescapés
n'ont pas trouvé mieux que de réserver
l'exclusivité de leurs récits à paris
match pour 600 mille francs
les frais de leur sauvetage s'élever
tout même à 300 mille francs
interrogé sur le sujet l'un d'entre eux
a même proféré des menaces physiques à
l'encore d'une équipe de journalistes de
france 2 avec ces trois messieurs
l'expression crétins des alpages a donc
pris toute sa dimension vont rejoindre
une équipe de journalistes d'un grand
hebdomadaire parisien
un contrat a été signé pour des photos
et le récit de l'aventuré on parle de
600 mille francs voire plus qui va payer
l'oim a souri sarah sol un fait tout à
fait rassurant ça que vous avez signé un
contre un china resigned écourtant cela
à l'écran balle prochaine pour cause moi
je te mets web opera la gueule tu as
compris bon soit pas je pense que la pac
on ramène à notre avantage des valeurs
que co que là ils ont été vraiment sur
ces épouvantables et ils ont versé au
moins ils ont remboursé les sommes
annoncées 300000 ils ont gardé trois
cents mieux mais oui ils sont pas
ridicules
ouais voilà bravo isabelle parce que
c'est le mot juste
enfin ces trophées de l'ignoble alors on
va terminer avec thierry démarez le
patron de total fina total final c'est
la compagnie qui avait affrété le
pétrolier erika dont le naufrage est en
train de polluer nos plages sa
nomination thierry démarez l'a acquise
en offrant royalement victimes de la
marée noire une journée de son salaire
soit 30000 francs avec ça ils ont pu
s'acheter 140 pelles râteaux et sow pour
aller nettoyer les plages
le groupe pétrolier montrait du doigt
est jugée responsable de l'accident de
l'erika et sa stratégie de communication
n'a pas corriger cette impression
lorsqu'il arrive à matignon thierry
desmarest a toutes ces données en tête
une heure d'entretien avec lionel jospin
et sur le perron l'annoncent que total
va mettre la main au portefeuille
donner une heure de vos revenus pour ça
sera du spectaculaire ça non c'est une
demande qui ferait du bien apparemment
vous êtes prêts à donner je suis prêt
d'honneur de
de ma rémunération et si on commençait
ce matin une journée vous êtes prêt à
offrir une journée ça représente combien
d'argent pour l'association
écoutez restant ces gens prient sur le
sujet que nous avons aujourd'hui on
était tout à l'heure sur une heure une
journée ça fera huit fois une heure ça
démarre et ouais ouais je suis carrément
pour le boycott de total jusqu'à ce qu'
ils remboursent l'intégralité des frais
de ce qu'ils ont fait mais je suis c'est
à dire comment il paraît que tout
il pourrait faire ça de tout son sens
que ça leur coûte un sou total oui parce
que très franchement total et f on sait
que maintenant ils sont les ont fusionné
ses depuis l'été dernier total f
ils ont quand même quelqu'un qu'ils ont
payé fortune et qui peut très bien
servir c'est christine deviers-joncour
oui elle a servi à pompe et roland dumas
n'y a pas de raison qu'elles servent pas
pompé l'erika maintenant rassurés bon
alors on va voter comme d'habitude je
m'attends tout le monde demain décide de
le faire on peut boycotter total jusqu'à
ce qu'il rencontre mois c'est trop con
j'ai eu 9 points total 10e ginestas
piché statuette de roland dumas dont je
peux pas m'arrêter là
après ça je suis obligé d'aller jusqu'au
10e poids total on passe au vote comme
d'habitude commet stéphane alors on peut
pas battre paco rabanne m6 démarre et
ridicule paco rabanne gérard souscrit
évidemment ridicule de paco rabanne mais
je trouve qu'on n'a pas tellement
l'occasion à la télévision de taper sur
les patrons donc pour une fois qu'on
peut décerner un trophée mais un petit
peu désagréable un patron au volet
solidaire qui est vraiment bien gentil
donc je choisis plutôt des marais des
marais oui
non je faisais aussi paco rabanne on
souvient plus que sur ce plateau
on avait la présence de notre ami
regretté alain gillot-pétré et paco
rabanne avait lancé un sort quasiment il
avait foudroyés comme ça le regarde et à
mon avis voilà paco rabanne y est pour
quelque chose qu'il a vraiment le droit
à tous les trophées les plus sales au
parc on peut lui alors moi c'est
évidemment paco rabanne mais je voudrais
ajouter à lui toute la corporation des
charlatans en tous genres qui arrive
toujours à manipuler les gens qui sont
trop trop naïf quoi donc paco rabanne et
tous ses acolytes de ses robes qui était
quand même franchement pas terrible
c'est pas vrai ça moquera perd donc
c'est paco rabanne à l'unanimité voyons
si oui mais c'est pas facile à porter
tous les jeudis
on a catégorie société
paco rabanne qui ont
le groupe
gül on est passé à côté mais ce qu'on
peut dire c'est que chez paco rabanne ya
que les robes qui soit voyante linda
hardy aura droit dans cette émission à
une séquence où elle pose les questions
et ça vous tombe et c'est derrière ce
sera un plaisir non elle va vous
interviewez tout à l'heure l'interview
sexe j'en suis ravi
et je suis ravi que tu mets choisis
médias et laurence avec guy bedos et
florence belkacem
l'humoriste en pré retraite et la
journaliste de réanimer ensuite sur
canal bienvenue en france
mais le pilote de l'émission est une
cata elle restera donc à l'état de
projet en plus les deux présentateurs ne
s'entendait pas florence belkacem
affirme que l'alliance de la carte jeune
et de la carte vermeil n'a pas
fonctionné ce à quoi répond bedos
elle devrait arrêter avec sa carte jeune
elle frise point de la quarantaine bon
esprit
canal+ a tellement agité pour filmer ma
retraite alors qu'ils avaient déjà
gildas sous la main à la rentrée qu'il
veut nous devait présenter avec florence
belkacem un magazine d'interviews de
samedi à 19h30 à l'issue du pilote
jamais diffusés vole à ce qu'ils en
pensaient l'émission était absolument
navrante
de longues heures etc voilà donc byblos
non c'est vrai il faisait beaucoup rire
mes grands-parents en hommage à mes
grands parents je pourrais je me plais
de giscard oui
alors deux ça fait très longtemps que
t'as pas passer une de mes chansons pop
abusez pas souri à d'accord alors 2e
posture courir passe le témoin
je t'aime
tous les camps
voilà
vous me dites deuxième postulants au
titre les guignols qui ont allumé
pendant des mois à l'antenne guillaume
durand l'ex-présentateur de nulle part
ailleurs même le jour de sa présentation
là je vais la faire celle là je trouve
c'est un truc ce serait génial c'est que
puisqu'il ya un prompteur et un texte ne
le disent tous
oui voilà on vient on est tous le
prompteur rien on va essayer autant
qu'on le fasse collectivement voulait
pas venir ses fans michel gardes alors
mes foulées des souvenirs de nancy 1-2
3-2 par ailleurs même le chalet de jours
de l'aviation sur canal
d'ailleurs le public présent sur le
plateau ne s'y est pas trompé aussi fort
qu'au mieux voir les lionnes a réuni
derrière
la baisse durant du coup ce sens nous
tenons donc à lui dire publiquement que
nous l'aimons bien que le reste est
tombé que nous lui souhaitons un prompt
rétablissement puisque vous avez pu
constater ces derniers temps il était
absent de l'antenne depuis deux ans la
tjv en soir ce soir la ppd semble avoir
fait un bide c'est pas normal c'est plus
possible on n'est plus dans un système
comme ça on peut faire les émissions
avec des types qui sont planqués
derrière des marionnettes qui tient
surtout au final donc je soutiendrai les
guignols parce que grâce à eux j'ai
failli avoir la palme du ridicule oui
avec ma marionnette alors mais bon j'y
suis patient qui voulant donner avoue
stéphane bern oui oui j'assume je suis
ravi d'être ridicule bien
attendez on termine vers le ciel encore
la dernière nomination et pour
christophe dechavanne son acte le plus
ridicule de l'année 99 avoir détourné
une estelle halliday animatrice une
première saison le samedi soir sur
france 2 elle était produite par
messieurs gâteau ils recevront entre
temps un rencontre de chabanais celui-ci
la débauche
il devient le producteur de deux mille
mercis toujours le samedi soir toujours
sur france 2 est toujours avec estelle
mais ce qui est parfaitement ridicule
c'est qu'avec ses premiers producteurs
l'émission atteignait 25 % d'audience
avec dechavanne seulement 16% à 6
s'était alors produite par stéphane
gâteau et jérôme revon et puis au
printemps elle a fait une rencontre
la terre ne s'arrête pas là puisque la
rentrée 99 et stella l'idée abandonne
les producteurs qui l'ont lancée pour
venir travailler avec christophe
dechavanne
j'ai fait mon métier j'ai rien fait de
mal j'ai fait vivre
j'ai pas agi on peut vraiment garder
quelqu'un sait ce qu'il faut pour
on lui disait eh bien oui c'est que ils
sont tous très teigneux qui sont tous
méchants bedos et méchant les guignols
sont méchants on est on est on est pas
dans le ridicule sympathique là on est
dedans il faut charger info alors face
au vote
stéphane j'hésitais bedeau sans conteste
oui oui oui parce que j'aime bien j'aime
bien dechavanne j'aime bien guillaume
durand et des guignols de soins gérard
pas une seconde dose soit absolument pas
en quoi il a été victime
belkacem c'est surtout ce côté là c'est
vraiment ce qu'il faut être galant s'est
plutôt bien sorti de cet immeuble à
l'angle des grands même un peu 6/10 et
s'ils avaient d'ailleurs à ce propos
cette histoire un trophée du ridicule
c'est plutôt pour le nommer de greffe
oui il dirige canada et c'est bon c'est
beaucoup plus agréable de donner des
trophées du ridicule à des gens
puissants cas des gens faibles
c'est donc là se trouve c'est plus
amusant de le donner à 2h30 sans même
nous en rendre
compris ces histoires de 25 16 % donc
alors vous en verrez jamais avec twitter
de ça ici mais je vois pas en quoi c'est
ridicule je comprendre c'est un flop je
comprends qu'il n'a pas réussi à faire
ce qu'il devait faire mais je vois pas
pourquoi ce serait ridicule
du coup je suis pour le dire le donner
aux guignols que j'aime évidemment bien
mais je trouve que c'est pas mal un
moment donné de leur taper un peu sur le
bec très bien donc les guignols pour
gérard miller vous souhaitez bedos
l'envoie pas beau ça vous ferait trop
plaisir pas les guignols parce que
franchement c'est utile les guignols à
la santé est alors par élimination
dechavanne même si moi aussi je m'en
fous un peu d histoire des stèles
hallyday voix reconnaît qu'effectivement
c'est pas terrible mais c'est déjà à mon
goût pas terrible avant de tous les sens
enfin c'est quand même pour lui que je
file comme ça parce que c'est celui qu'a
nation une fois connaissent vous calé
départager le suspense bat moi c'est les
guignols délibérément parce que je
trouve qu'ils sont vraiment pétri
d'autosatisfaction ils sont beaucoup
plus drôle quand il s'attaque aux gens
que tout le monde connaît que quand ils
se moquent de la queue entre s'attaquer
entre eux ça n'a aucun intérêt
là l'histoire de se moquer les gens
saluent un texte un conte un tel saint
machin bon est ce que quand les gens
font ça ils le font pour rire comme
disait isabelle où ils le font pour de
bon parce qu'à ce moment là si c'est
pour rire c'est pas grave de dire untel
est ridicule ou tel mais si c'est pour
lui faire du mal ou faire de la peine
c'est grave de dire hey lalala di cule
bien donc on continue on passe au score
au rayon sport les organisations sport
pour l'obtention du tout peur du
ridicule sont tout d'abord celui qui
déclare qu'il est pour le dopage c'est à
dire pour une grosse prévention le
cycliste richard virenque a entendu même
prix la seringue dans le sac
en 99 il a continué à terme et qui ne se
dopait pas en effet il soigne son rhume
et où les médecins vous le diront la
fira façon de soigner son rhume c'est de
prendre de la page existe oui ça existe
dans tous les sports une seule chose que
je regrette mon le cyclisme ça existe
mais qu' il fléau dopage sur le coureur
cycliste mais nous convainc cyclistes on
est bien gentil parce qu'on accepte
beaucoup de choses que certains sports
et ben ils acceptent même pas le quart
de ce qu'on donne donc moi je suis pour
le dopage c'est à dire que pour qu'une
grosse prévention pour le contrôler ou
le contrôle c'est à dire je veux très
pas produit parce qu on n'achève pas
quand même à lui asséner deux coups dans
la gueule quoi ça suffit comme ça c'est
vraiment vouloir de parler alors qu'il
est payé pour pédaler l'obligé à notre
client pour vous c'est le deuxième
candidat c'est le footballeur nicolas
anelka
là je me demande si c'est lui le plus
ridicule ou si ce sont les dirigeants du
real de madrid et le club espagnol qui
l'a achetée 220 millions de francs en
échange les le cas n'a pas marqué le
moindre but avec le real en 99 0 but
égale 220 millions de francs mais ne
soyons pas mauvaise langue en 2000
anelka a déjà marqué trois buts lors de
la coupe du monde des clubs au brésil
ce qui fait dire aux journalistes de la
presse sportive espagnole le bug de l'an
2000 a bien eu lieu
anelka a marqué la pression
arsenal y avait autant de pression que
correa de marie dépensé façon j'ai
essayé de faire le mieux possible quand
je pense quelque chose je lui dis je dis
la vérité tout simplement et que des
fois ça fait mal mais ça fait toujours
du bien de dire la vérité je regarde pas
les laits millions façon ne sont pas
pour moi première - et moi ça me fait
rien du tout moi je suis là pour jouer
je suis venu j'ai signé je viens pour
m'amuser sur lequel avec michel en plus
il s'est pété le genou cette semaine
avec le real on continue avec les
footballeur on continue on termine avec
fabien barthez pour se couvrir de
ridicule le gardien de l'équipe de
france de foot n'a pas trouvé mieux que
de faire en 99 la pub pour un hamburger
les publicitaires l'ayant convaincue
qu'il y avait une analogie entre son
crâne chauve et le dessus du 10
hamburgers mais il ya aussi un autre
point commun entre le crâne de barthez
et hamburgers halal travailleurs se
trouvent dans les deux cas quand dijon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et bien voici venue l'heure du vote bien
c'est pas moi je vote pour elle nicolas
anelka parce que je trouve ça on râle
toujours la fortune des rois etc
mais la fortune des footballeurs on
ferait bien la dénoncer quand ils sont
encore d'incompétents bailly se bouger
pions pas savoir à l'avancé les bains
marqué 2 buts non plus pour garçons
maintenant j'ai envie l'air moi je le
rendrai celle dont je ne connais
absolument pas les noms j'ai simplement
beaucoup de sympathie pour vivre un gain
depuis le début et ça ne se dément pas
et sont les honda par maître collard
pas du tout parce que je n'ai aucune
sympathie sans être polar mais virage
j'ai toujours eu la sympathie pour sa
difficulté à s'expliquer et donc
certainement pas virac
c'est vrai que je ne connaissais pas
anelka donc je vais te dire barthez
faute de mieux et aller le cabardès
alors moi plutôt anelka parce que en
plus quand même on a oublié mais il a
fait une pub on l'a vu dans tous les
magazines pour le déodorant en art avec
avec une serviette la halle et c'est
vrai qu'à 200 combien c'était le
transfert de 120 millions de francs donc
rappelé qu'en plus ils pu sous les bras
d'américains alors donc vraiment c'est
pour lui le trophée
isabelle bas moi c'était virenque parce
que j'en ai trop marre du foot et on
parle que des footeux et finalement
virenque en s'entêtant dans cette
position on dit que le ridicule tue mais
lui c'est le maintien au fait de
l'actualité donc formellement mais c'est
aussi un ridicule sympathique je trouve
bizarre il a été conquis
le plus ridicule peut-être celle ont
dansé et fait l'erreur barthez avait
fâché pas j'aime moi j'aimerais bien que
c'est ça des making quand même une
certaine aura par rapport à leur public
et qui choisissent mieux leurs pubs dont
l'un disait par rapport à ce qu'on nous
vend etc
les américains et tous peut-être ce
serait bien que les managers autour de
leur dise de bons profits du ridicule
non c'est nicolas anelka dans la
catégorie
ridicule bien bas merci entre les cajas
les collections merci donc stéphane bern
merci beaucoup
maintenant vous avez tort gros mot
science comment
j'ai sorti mon album seul frein
craignais pour son jubilé en février je
sors chez albin michel mon royaume à moi
pour répondre non non c'est pas pour
prendre au sérieux mais pour raconter
comment on tombe tout petit dans le
gotha très bien gérard miller on vous
retrouve chez michel drucker tous les
dimanches main demain avec douste-blazy
avec tous le blay demeurent vains très
bien je fais de la télé maintenant
pardon et bien de la télé motion bien
truquée la toile affaires n'ont voulu
laisser d'après midi pour l'instant on
vous retrouve tous les matins sur europe
1 et tous les après midi avec on va
s'gêner c'est à 16h30
là le matin à 8h45 et avec la bande
l'après midi à 16h30 jusqu'à 18 heures
et vous aussi
et prend dix ans il s'appelle comment
ils s'appellent tous les hommes sont
égaux à eux mêmes les femmes chez robert
laffont voilà on l'a reçue c'était
terrible
je me suis fait engueuler soir c'est une
vraie celle de garde ces nouvelles
scènes de gaz me suis bien fait ramasser
vous restez avec nous à un son encore
quelques petites choses cette année
[Musique]
maintenant regardez la bande annonce
d'un film qui sort mercredi qui
s'appelle épouse moi un film d'art y est
marin avec vincent perez et michèle
laroque que nous accueillerons après la
bande annonce
dites moi s'il reste une chance de
sauver mon mariage
vous êtes ce [ __ ] contre marie pour
rien beau tir
une fois le pc le parti
[Musique]
surprise ma fiancée jamais vu les deux
bouts des deux premiers de remercier le
sait mais la regarde comme ça m elle lui
rappelle une écolière demeurait à ce
point là je vous prédis un avenir
radieux mais c'est de la concurrence
sauvage ça alors qu'un diplôme c'est moi
qui de façon de le montrer non non je
veux juste un peu d'ambiance
désolé mais je peux pas accepter ça mais
qu'est-ce que vous juste je veux une fin
heureuse
des caresses de 6,6 des marolles par des
paroles en espagnol
quelle souplesse veux mon mari ce je
suis ma joie par les matons clamaient
des douze mois d'arrière marins avec
michèle laroque que nous accueillons
initial
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir il ya des trucs ici qui font
tomber les ja l'itc pour les
déstabiliser
on est est en fait un bond michel sapin
surtout pas y toucher 1 épouse moi oui
oui dans quelques mois vincent perez
avec audrey tautou réel et vu dans vénus
beauté institut est nominé aux césars
que nominé aux césar pour quel film pour
vénus beauté institut et c'est bien et
alors c'est une comédie romantique c'est
l'histoire de votre histoire vous
appelez oriane dans le film oriane roche
votre fils s'il s'appelle la fille
oriane aussi oui c'est à cause de proust
c'est ça oui ça vaut rien de guermantes
ray j'aime bien tout le monde s'appelle
lauriane quoi alors elle est prête à
tout pour sauver son mariage se dispute
avec son mari qui s'appelle adrien qui
est joué par vincent perez lors il ya un
peu un problème entre eux c'est à dire
qu'on fait avant d'être avec vincent
perez elle était avec le meilleur ami
c'est ça c'est ça puis quand on mène ont
séquencé mais s'est jetée par la fenêtre
alors non ça jette un froid et vain si
vous n'êtes pas mariée avec ma chambre
c'est oui parce qu'on s'aime vraiment et
moi au bout d'un an je pense qu'on a
essayé de résister mais on s'est quand
même marié et père d'un moment j'ai
réussi à avancer a évolué et puis le
personnage de vincent mahé et
culpabilise lui son amour avec moi à
cause de sa calandre à eyes détruisent
des familles j'adore jouer alors je suis
obligé de me bat mais oui ça nous faire
comprendre comme toutes les femmes vous
allez voir je veux pas raconter le film
en gros le l'histoire si vous allez voir
un mayans key l'avenir un voyant qu'il
avait dans une boule de cristal et là on
a trois versions la première n'a de en
fait oui la première mais comme
l'algérie un peu têtu quand même mon
personnage dans quel univers samedi
voilà l'avenir ça va être s'agit non ça
me plaît pas les lundis ben oui mais
qu'est ce que je peux faire donc je sais
pas j'arrive à le persuader il arriva
c'est pas à provoquer autre chose il ya
une deuxième version qui me plaît pas
non plus parce que je termine pas avec
mon mari ne parvient pas c'est lui que
je veux donc après fort de tout ce qui
m'a raconté je me rends compte que ça
tout va commencer le soir même et je
vais lutter contre le destin elle sa
vrai portrait l'amoureuse un trait sans
perez il est magnifique
guilbeault comment on peut tourner avec
vincent perez sans tomber amoureuse de
lui moi je suis pas très acteurs sénat
donc voilà cette fois rugbyman
oui voilà oui très rugbyman mais c'est
vrai tout de suite vous avez su agen 10
mars et fit donc une belle carrière au
cinéma jusqu'à maintenant où tout le
monde se souvient de [ __ ] douce
faisait rapporté une fortune ce film
ce qui vous regarde pas beaucoup
d'argent donc beaucoup d'argent parce
que vous étiez payer au pourcentage
ouais les jolies yassap ya un autre film
aussi dont on a moins parlé qui
s'appelle ma vie en rose d'alain berline
avec un très beau et qui alors aux etats
unis c'est une sorte de film culte non
mais ça marchait bien on a eu le golden
globe du film étranger
et puis effectivement il paraît qu'on
trouve bon maintenant c'est plus en
salle aux états unis mais on trouve
jamais les cassettes dans les magasins
c'est un site magnifique
donc voilà aux états unis d'un temps
vous allez en face ils moins bien sûr on
retenait et puis sur les planches
vous avez fait ils s'aiment avec notre
ami papa palmade
mais oui mais c'était plutôt très gai
oui c'est un peu comme vous avec le
démon de midi ça ça wily plus ça n'en
finit plus de tacles mais ce film qui
sort la wii vivir nous oui enfin en même
temps vous continuez toujours à jouer
votre pièce un peu partout mais oui je
suis en tournée en france anciennement
oui absolument
non mais pourquoi pas c'est bien de
pouvoir faire des films du théâtre le
sellier en a tellement qu'on roule bien
là mais on était michel oui à celle
secret alors envie de boussou grand
michèle laroque que vous êtes la
nouvelle jacqueline maillan sept mois 10
à drogba et muriel oui c'est très
bizarre ça veut dire que vous pouvez
être aussi des nouvelles
virgo besco parce que vous êtes
d'origine roumaine c'est une histoire
formidable à la fin des années 50 la
roumanie était sous la botte de
ceausescu et votre mère qui s'appelait
domine à ses professeurs et en même
temps qui était danseuse dans une troupe
folklorique elle est passée à l'ouest
échapper elle s'est échappée choisi la
liberté femmes sont formidables elle a
profité d'un voyage pour passer à
l'ouest
elle s'est réfugiée à nice il a épousé
votre père voilà qui dirige un
laboratoire pharmaceutique
lorsque très marrant c'est que parce que
très branché dans la famille des votes
psg plutôt polytechnicien cd tête ses
déplacements ils ont tous fait les
napolitains et votre grand temps qu'il a
inventé la fin le grand est sécuritaire
sociale sécurité sociale
on sait pas de quel homme j invite pas
n'importe quel fait rien fait avec mon
père à mort le 15 juin 1960 nice-matin
couverture de nice-matin naissance du
bébé de la liberté c'était michèle
laroque
on l'appelle au bébé la liberté si vous
étiez célèbre déjà en déficit en
connaissant un vous a été levée que
cette histoire se faisant rabattu les
oreilles pour ça que je me fais encore
une fois vous a bien battu les aurais
pas après on a plus parlé mais je
trouvais ça normal
bon maintenant c'est vrai comment ça que
ça fasse à ressorts relevé la liberté
c'est pas tous les jours c'est vrai
alors j'ai grandi votre père il était en
fait ce qui est très bien c'est que
votre père lui il était plutôt un mec
sérieux au départ ils vous forcer à
faire des blagues
les travaux fort cette farce oui alors
la peau vous avez grand mais c'est vrai
que c'était terrible j'ai eu une enfance
à 100 c c'est à dire que son père l'a
forcé à faire des blagues alors il a
tâché par exemple à un portefeuille dans
la rue avec un fils métissée mais de
deux à trois genres oui c'est 3 août
annoncée ou de 2 à 4 ce que je veux dire
c'est quand ils voulaient lui quoi
écouta font envie ça ne fait pas rire
tu fais pendant une heure d'attenté et
un mec qui passe et hop tu retires et
lui hors mourir je suis encore d'accord
mais là que force à faire mes devoirs et
toi c'était sale jonas plutôt sympa bon
alors retenir ses terres il fallait
qu'elle fasse michèle laroque
voyez les enfants d'aller voir ce que
c'est pour devenir star piano dans ce
champ tennis équitation théâtre mais
j'ai fait pareil
obama était obsédé par ça avant ah oui
il sortait d'un milieu très très moyen
très très même bad basque lazer disait
toujours il faut qu'un jour tu va
fréquenter que des gens comme ça parce
que dans la tête de mon père c'était
obligatoire et donc apprend être comme
ça tu ne seras jamais tout seul
donc c'est vrai que je peux faire un peu
de tennis un peu de cheval non mais
c'est vrai je ne m'ennuie jamais dans le
gotha le cp berne d'être là tout à
l'heure mais je peux jouer au tennis et
que c'est pour ça qu'on vous a mis à
côté alors que votre mère tout devenu
une corvée quoi parce que vous n'avez
jamais eu envie de quelque chose on sait
tout de suite allé vers jamais dit oh
tiens j'aimerais nombreux alors tu vas
faire ça ça ça fait que oui c'est pas
très marrant dur jeunesse vous étiez un
petit peu une adolescente un peu un peu
faisait un peu bande à part d'une
certaine façon vous étiez timide pas non
mais c'est vrai vous regardiez pas la
télé d'ailleurs vous dites depuis rome
si tu apportes si c'est vrai je sais pas
vous raconter arthur par exemple vous
n'êtes pas eu des enfants de la télé en
planant c'est ça que j'arrive patronne
en plus je regardais pas la télé mais
ouais
j'écoutais des recadrages est-ce que
vous écoutiez du rock'n'roll au moins
oui ouais ouais
et vous dites dans la vie dans la vie je
me fais tout petit je suis plus en jeu
marquait ses charmants pour un mec je
suis plus en observation quand
démonstration ça c'est vrai oui mais ça
dépend j'ai des crises de démonstration
quand même heureusement mais c'est vrai
que j'aime bien regarder un don vous
avez un truc en commun avec florence
arthaud c'est que vous avez un accident
de voiture et les voitures
l'érection de voitures ya un peu comme
florence arthaud d'ailleurs qu'ils
étaient ici la semaine dernière c'est
que cet accident vous a fait prendre
conscience de la réalité c'est sympa ça
bouge on est dans le bon sens
il était bien amoché quand même hein ah
oui je suis resté un an sans marcher le
fémur en 18 morceaux qui a éclaté
he a atteint 2 ans qui nie pas rêver
quelles économies dans des choses et
après le film bad justement de dépense
énormément d'argent chaussures quelques
infimes là dessus un peu non crash non
avec rachou et et vous dites d'ailleurs
au réveil d'une espèce de révélations
comme ça et vous dit j'aurais pu mourir
sans savoir si j'étais une bonne actrice
et c'est là que vous décidez d'aller au
conservatoire de nice à venir marcher
évidemment au conservatoire donne peu de
cours à l'hôpital louis-h
et pour une fois j'ai eu envie d'un truc
voilà on m'avait pas trop forcer à jouer
la comédie avant donc leur colère vous a
laissé faire ce coup là à la wii cette
fois-ci oui lésions à faire là vous
allez vous avez pas bougé pendant que la
lumière se baisse et on va faire une
petite interview à peine down
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pas mal plus dur dans cette émission
c'est ça pour moi c'est une question
qu'est ce qu'être plusieurs danses
étaient bien alors interview open dames
les hauts et les bas de la vie de prêtre
le plus grand moment de votre vie je
crois que je crois que c'est la
naissance de ma fille oriane way le pire
moment
soyez pro mon adolescence ah oui voilà
vaches je souhaite à personne
ah ouais ascquois la terrible terrible
voire bain en espèces une espèce de de
rejet de mois terribles 2
vous savez pas quoi ah oui non de envie
de détruire et de ça a été très dur et
quand je dis adolescence et peut-être
pas tout l'adolescence c'est bien trois
ans c'est long j'étais très très très
très mal vous aidez vous êtes très jolie
faisait déjà très joli mais je sais on
sait pas moi je savais pas non je n'ai
pas des garçons pour vous le dire que
vous étiez très joli mais c'est pas on
s'en fout de ce qu'on dit enfin je veux
dire c'est ce que mon sens et je me
sentais vraiment pas bien
non je vous préférez dans la vie rires
vous détestez dans la bible dit papa
rire parce que les faux gentil à j'aime
pas ça voilà ce qui vous fait le plus
rire dans la vie mais justement ce que
je disais j'aime bien regarder les gens
tu vois pas ce que tu t'es pareil que et
comme tout à l'heure vous disiez la boue
sur le ridicule justement on aime ça
parce que c'est donc c'est un peu soit
aussi quand même quoi comment on peut
l'être
voilà ça ça me fait énormément rire de
voir des gens un peu déstabilisé leurs
réactions et puis se dire j'avoue moi
j'aurais fait comment tu fais le moins
rire mais elle n'est pas drôle les gens
qui se croient drôles et qu'ils sont pas
alors ça c'est un peu pathétique
ma plus belle histoire d'amour je sais
pas c'est encore vrai j'ai un bon donc
on demande aussi à ses joueurs c'est une
super bonne nouvelle je le dis à nos
amis téléspectateurs et la plus minable
non c'est toujours oui alors voilà
justement non c'est toujours intéressant
on adore d'amour c'est le minable
d'accord avec ça vous à votre est tout à
fait vous semblez au moment où la vie on
pense que c'est génial
donc on va lentement que basse et lyon
demain quand il ya plus personne n'est
pas ce que vous n'êtes plus sexy en vous
non j'adore ça 6 va répondre moi ce que
j'ai
là c'est la façon qu'elle a toujours de
baisser les yeux
moi
vous en pensez quoi sexy le plus sexy
qui prend pas ce qu'est la 6è louis les
petites rides sur le nez quand elle rit
il
je pense qu'il se bat quand on s'étripe
[Rires]
soulagés grâce à toi francis merci pour
les rides cluzel mois sexy mais j'ai les
jambes tendues
ah bon non non vous n'êtes pas content
j'ai tordu 18 fois que j'avais des
jambes arquées je suis tout petit et
elles sont toutes les citations
c'était des petits chevaux tout petit
voilà ce que vous préférez dans le sexe
c'est dernière question alors ça j'aime
beaucoup de choses mais ce que je
préfère
y avoir un court il soufflait pas les
mêmes non franchement j'ai pas d'idée
thierry bel amour déjà à l'amour mais le
sexe bah ouais pas encore ici bah oui
parce qu'il y avait des sens et des
banquiers c'est mieux quand vous
détestez dans le sexe bas les mauvais
coups avant vous avez oui c'est ça les
filles d'aujourd'hui un bon je crois que
c'est comme ça depuis longtemps mais on
ne sait pas le dire sans traduiront par
allumer la lumière s'allume et bien on
va passer au croque monsieur de francis
lalanne ça va se retrouver enfin tous
les deux enfin assez la musique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous avez écrit des poèmes vous avez
écrit un recueil de poèmes et vous
disent quelque chose de surprenant vie
sont des poèmes à lire avant de faire
l'amour dans la question que je me pose
c'est ce qu'on fait mieux l'amour après
avoir un livre après avoir lu vos poèmes
c'était un mot c'est un mot je sais pas
je sais pas répondre à cette question
faudrait la poser à ceux qui font
l'amour les années à essayer au moins
deux autres femmes
mais il m'arrive d'en écrire moi oui
d'en écrire mais vous pouvez lui avoir
lu moi je dis bien donc c'est embêtant
bah oui faut bien avant moi j'aime bien
mais là je trouve qu'on a besoin de mots
aussi dans l'amour quoi on a besoin a
pas besoin que de ges on a besoin de
mots voilà ce que je voulais dire en
fait simplement comment est-ce que vous
réagissez face à une femme sexuellement
provocante ce dépens c'est à dire que ce
soit ça peut ça peut déclencher chez moi
l'envi de m'amuser avec ce qu'elle croit
provoqué chez moi donc je vais je vais
m'amuser avec ça c'est à dire que je
vais lui faire croire que que sa
provocation
donc vous entrez dans un jeu ou alors
qu'un jeu de séduction qui
qui va pas aller au bout ou alors
carrément j'essaie de lui parler d'autre
chose on aurait pu on va reprendre cette
interview au début et en fait on va même
pas faire d'interview
on va faire une entrevue parce que comme
on est en france on va plutôt faire une
entrevue qu'une interview par exemple
est alors votre bus parce que tout ce
qui s'est passé s'est passé jusque là
bas n'a pas vraiment d'intérêt parce que
il a violé notre à lui vous voulez qu'on
vous laisse là oui oui vraiment à violer
alors qu'on va faire on va lancer comme
il comme il avant d interviews des
entrevues on va lancer la double la
double entre vous l'interview réciproque
voilà l'interview à 6 propre nom est ce
que est ce que c est ce que la première
fois que vous avez regardé un garçon est
ce que vous avez pensé
il est beau est ce que vous avez pensé
il est tendre ou es ce que vous avez
pensé j'ai envie de m'en fous
probablement il est tendre sûrement pas
j'ai envie de m'enfuir
et il est beau ça veut pas dire grand
chose ouais dans votre vie de leurs vous
avez dit un jour à quelque chose
d'incroyable c'était g j'ai un besoin
sexuel ou du moins votre médecin le
disais j'ai un besoin sexuel énorme
alors comment est ce que vous faites
dans votre vie de tous les jours puisque
maintenant vous êtes avec d'autres
femmes depuis longtemps pour justement
éviter cette routine sexuelle
je crois que quand on a des besoins
sexuels important c'est que quelque part
on a un manque
puis quand on arrive à combler souvent
que mal problème de la sexualité active
au départ oui donc le problème de
sexualité passe au second plan
bon bah voilà attention donc commencé
ses bases et alors c'était bien que t'es
pas là bien maintenant nous allons
recevoir un homme politique je dis pas
un homme politique drôle parce que c'est
le seul à être drôle et la même aucun
mérite à être drôle si andré santini
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir bien alors andré santini vous
êtes maire d'issy les moulineaux depuis
1981 c'est pas eu le trophée du ridicule
vous avez deux marianne dehors vous hein
c'est mieux vous êtes vous avez été
secrétaire d'état aux rapatriés ministre
de la communication vous êtes vous avez
été vice président de l'assemblée
nationale de ce mariage manqué oui c'est
beau mais les mecs que j'invite tous et
ce alors dû rien du tout je vous
raconterai mais c'est bien pour vous
vous écoutez les hauts-de-seine
vous êtes député des hauts-de-seine oui
voilà et
vous êtes un enfant de la banlieue est
finalement votre père avait un café à
courbevoie
votre mère est employée des postes fait
vous êtes corse mais vous dites je suis
né à paris par ailleurs pendant la
guerre de l'erreur judiciaire de 40 ans
comme j'ai tout de suite là vous n'êtes
pas l'homme politique le plus drôle mais
le seul homme politique drôle et les
autres quand ils sont drôles ils ne font
pas exprès plus assez claire quand vous
avez beaucoup d'humour vous avez dit en
parlant de arpaillange sais pas si les
gens se souviennent encore d'art paille
ans qui était ministre de la justice du
temps de françois mitterrand saint louis
rendait la justice sous un chêne
arpaillange rend la justice comme un
gland député c'est bien vous êtes
l'inventeur de la célèbre formule le
gouvernement va dans le mur en plus ils
klaxonnent et en parlant à de courtrai
monseigneur de courtrai vous lui avez
dit vous n'avez rien compris aux
préservatifs la preuve vous l'avez mis à
l'index
c'est bien je goûte à jeter votre
périphérique la profitez-en oui je
m'attends au pire non alors est l'auteur
de neuf ouvrages aujourd'hui le 10ème
s'appelle je le montre à la caméra comme
on fait à la télévision voilà ça
s'appelle des v6 et des lanternes et
c'est publié aux éditions 1
voilà pour en finir avec la république
des experts vous en prenez aux experts
tous les cyclistes tous les gens qui
s'érigent les futurologues les les
cassandre les madame soleil enfin oui
vous avez eu tout récemment quand même
un truc pas mal avec la météo qui dit on
avait prévu ce qui s'est passé ouais
mais pas à 20 % prennent effectivement
cessé les 20% qui vivent de la
différence et les dégâts dus
du cèdre puisque c'est un centre
d'organiser un organisme chez pourquoi
payés par total paraît-il pour dire ce
qu'il ya pollution par les papilles au
talent vous avez vous à les énerver
lalanne
ah bon a dit formellement il n'y aura
pas de pollution il rien qu'elle
n'atteindra pas les côtes c'est quand
même extraordinaire ça c'est les
discours mais bien sûr ce sont des gens
qu'on paye pour ça alors vous vous avez
quand même une qualité c'est qu'en
commençant enfin vous dit pas en
commençant mais vous dites sur la
quatrième de couverture
vous dites avoir voté giscaro 80 ha bah
en 88 et balladur en 95 on vous dit tout
de suite moi j'suis pas si je vais pas
me dépose donc je suis complètement
avant chioui déjà avant d'entrer vous
dit ce qu'on va essayer de faire tout à
l'heure ils ont deux ans donne des
trophées du ridicule mais on est un
petit peu nous mêmes bon alors vous en
prenez aux experts économiques
on a quand même eu le club de rome ouais
qui juste avant 73 disait il faut
arrêter la croissance parce que vraiment
ça va exploser un an plus tard on se
retrouvait tout en short avec le pétrole
fr c'est quand même extraordinaire
on a eu on a eu aristide briand qui
déclarait jamais il n'y aura de guerre
avec l'allemagne des choses
extraordinaires et sur les 35 heures
alors c'est quoi à l'erreur des experts
tout le monde fait les 35 heures c'est
un phénomène idéologique qui a été
annoncé par les socialistes avec les
emplois-jeunes moment où il pensait pas
gagner parce qu'on leur a porté la
dissolution sur un plateau et quand on
est dans l'opposition on dit n'importe
quoi
manque de bol il arrive au pouvoir faut
y aller alors là je n'entendais que le
conseil constitutionnel venait
d'interdire la taxation d'un
supplémentaires au delà de x donc ça va
déséquilibrer le truc quand vous pensez
que madame voynet a dû créer une taxe
qu'on appelle la tgap la taxe générale
sur les pollutions tas qui va payer les
35 heures si vous voyez plus vous
polluez plus vous payez la réduction du
temps de travail
autre truc vous êtes contre les 35
heures mais je suis content parce que
c'est une mesure idiote qui ne
correspond à rien enfin il ya des
bouleaux franchement quand on a fait 35
heures par semaine la place et on a
autre chose c'est pareil pour la
retraite
waly fall encore il faut laisser
beaucoup de souplesse évidemment
quelqu'un qui travaille dans une mine
qui fait le ménage il mérite de prendre
sa retraite dès qu'ils le peuvent
d'accord qu'il ya des gens qui éclaire
d'un avion dès qu'il le peut surtout
parce que s'il en a envie et qui la
tient sans mal leur prête vous comprenez
qu'il ya tout ça aussi ouais enfin les
gabegies financières l'apa et de la
bibliothèque nationale de france dit
françois mitterrand c'est quoi la
gabegie l'un vous avez bien vu tout ce
qui s'est passé on on les parties là
encore d'une fausse idée le fait qu'il y
ait quatre tours qui ressemblait à deux
livres ouverts alors que tout le monde
sait que les livres il faut pas les
mettre à la lumière
donc je mets des volets ça commence
voilà alors des volets en bois des
volets commander des ige h ensuite on a
collé des espèces d'arbres extrêmement
rare précieuse
on a collé du bois sur lequel on casse
la gueule l'informatique est parti ça a
été le gigantesque bug sans qu'on l'ait
annoncé
c'est tout ça les gens disent c'est
quand même moi qui paye c'est ahurissant
vraiment bien là vous parlez de la
guerre du golfe vous dites c'était une
guerre chirurgicale de la guerre contre
la serbie
j'étais regard nintendo wii c'est une
guerre du golfe on n'a pas vu de on n'a
pas vu d'image pendant un certain temps
sont fous rappelez peut-être ce fameux
cormorans qui était sorti un jour est
complètement pollué moi j'ai même pas
qu'ils avaient des rochers mon corps est
donc j'ai dit tiens je le reconnaissent
leur mort ans il a déjà joué dans la
marque à 10
je dis ça parce que aujourd'hui on
ressort les malheureux cormorans et
c'était vrai il ya un écolo de service
qui a retrouvé les bobines qui a donc
constaté qu'on avait une guerre sans
images qu'on n'en rajoutait qu'à leur
ego et donc on n'a pas vu grand chose on
était terrorisé terré chez nous rappeler
qu'on n'osait pas sortir
on craignait des représailles on nous a
raconté qu l'armée de dire à qui était
la quatrième armée du monde l'ua s'est
écroulé comme une baudruche ans en
quelques heures et on a recommencé avec
le la guerre du du kosovo puisqu'on voit
actuellement qu'il y avait des tensions
entre les américains et les français que
le matériel ne convenait pas exactement
à ce genre de guerre puisqu'il fallait
taper sur un char planqué dans une ferme
à tel endroit sans éclabousser le
troupeau de moutons qui était juste à
côté
et c'était vraiment le lego 10,4 sur
leur console et les films qu'on a eu les
quelques films militaire qu'on a pu voir
c'est exactement ça moi je voyais des
gens qui courent à être terrain et je
trouve que c'est où se font un peu des
gens parce que on ne sera pas si on
pouvait faire autre chose s'il fallait
intervenir qu elle est le résultat par
exemple le fait de n'avoir pas prévu que
les serbes chasserait tous les kosovars
ou profiterait de la guerre pour en
exterminer une bonne part c'est quand
même on appelait ça un dommage
collatéral
on l'a fait pour le passé à la grammaire
mais pas de respect de l'homme il ya un
petit problème dans votre bouquin page
127 vous parlez de la vache folle et
vous dites qui croire autant conseillé
aux responsables politiques d'aller
consulter un astrologue les vous
les consulter les astrologues non non
non à chaque fois mais as aux
astrologues
je suis un des rares qui disent que
l'astrologie est un élément
d'information comme les autres d'autant
qu'il ya à peu près 20% des français qui
consultent commençait pas déjà à priori
xil charlatanerie qua non non mais ça a
toujours existé et de l'astrologie
sumérienne donc depuis très longtemps et
après l'argent l'astrologie chinoise est
d'ailleurs en france regardez françois
mitterrand il a d'abord écouté attali
après il a écouté elisabeth et c'est
vrai qu'après la goutelle téléphone donc
il a fait le parcours complet pour sa
forme est géré par des voyantes vous non
à vous non non vous toi donc je courus
ça c'est quand on veut tirer chaque fois
qu'on demande c'est comme les films
pornos jamais les films protégés par des
voyants de la minutie leur avoue
regarder quand même dans un petit sujet
là avant de passer à votre interview
spéciale parce que là je trouve bien
sérieux là subitement
s'être marié tape péché
cette nouvelle il me faut l'annoncer à
ma paroisse jeu
oui
j'ai pris une dose de whisky afin de
préparer mon serment
fait pas fermé l'oeil de la nuit blanche
question au petit matin vieux m'est
apparu
[Musique]
tu pouvais en l'église djebbour est mort
mais fidèle du roman
[Applaudissements]
mes bien chers frères mais bien sûr
[Musique]
soit
houdini avant de faire vos prières
devenu péché mortel je crois que par
votre père éternel
les fouilles ont dit n'avoir fait hier
le soir
andré santini
il a changé eddy mitchell ça crée une
très belle chanson ouais je ne connais
pas la musique et je ne connaissais pas
la chanson alors oui il ya peu le
connaissaient des chansons de francis
lalanne
et ben oui j'aime bien saisi la
prochaine fois vous avec l'équipe bon
sens dit non à faire une petite
interview à l'envers
m
j'ai un peu bougé mais bon alors je vous
donne la réponse
et vous me donnez la question balladur
avez vous des amis de trente ans très
bien chirac
qu'est-ce qui se rajoutent dissoudre
michèle alliot marie est ce qu'une femme
plus récemment s'imposer à des machos
lionel jospin balladur qui est ce qu'il
ya beaucoup de mal avec une majorité
plurielle qui est en train de devenir
une minorité active
[Rires]
je suis de mauvaise foi philippe seguin
d'après vous qui pourrait devenir maire
de paris douste-blazy ci ne fait pas une
apparition à lourdes il pourrait être
candidat à paris ou à toulouse
tiberi ce qui a une faille en tellement
belle qu'elle change de coiffure sans
faire de rapport santini qui est-ce qui
répond à une interview aussi stupide
depuis cinq minutes
l'inter milan va on n'appelle pas d'un
bord de glee un bon vous restez avec
nous là ça dépend pour quoi pour une
jolie dernier qui revient à n'ya pas
elle qui est un petit peu oui c'est une
jeune et jolie fille oui ça fera quatre
séverine ferrer
[Applaudissements]
il a servi une brute c'est michèle
laroque oui on se croisait oui je
connais c'est andré santini
oui c'est le dernier si cela date
concernant monsieur santini pardon vous
souvenez plus de moi michel de la
connaît et c'est pas pour dire mais
j'aime beaucoup et monsieur là là je
suis très content de vous rencontrer
ah bon voilà tout simplement parce que
vous aimez
paredes dans cette façon aussi je suis
super contente de vous rencontrer et
c'est sincère et je vous lis et linda
non je la connais pas vraiment bien on
se croise aussi il ya peu de temps et me
servait son oui je vous connais vous je
vous raconterai tout à l'heure voici me
laisser faire les choses enfin je vais
mettre en condition ah bon je note aussi
un vrai j'ai demandé qu'on mette le
jingle enfin comme jingle quand vous
rentriez barbie girl parakois parce que
vous êtes une fanatique des poupées
barbie
oui c'est vrai j'étais faire du chopper
en fin d'année à new york vous avez
sélectionné vous avez combien de poupée
barbie chez vous j'en avais 150 contre 8
à la réunion est aujourd'hui m'en reste
plus beaucoup mais j'ai en journée quand
même une cinquantaine avec des poupées
de collection
séverine faire a déclaré barbie a
longtemps représenté la femme que je
voulais devenir lorsque j'étais enfant
c'est fait loin du tout du tout enfin
elle a pas un pet grèce elle est belle
elle a des formes
elle est blonde rejeta blanc devra rater
du port du brusc promis elles sont moins
joli mais c'est pas grave hein je trouve
que maintenant la perfection ça ne veut
plus rien dire à bord je trouve qu'une
femme est beaucoup plus jolie avec ses
défauts ses rides en france
beaucoup d'enfants sont allés l'enfance
de du bd de la liberté tout à l'heure
vous avez été un bébé très libre aussi à
la réunion très jeune vous adoriez vous
produire en spectacle chanté dansé pour
le pour le voisinage
pas forcément pour le voisinage dans
l'île oui vous étés mini miss réunion à
sept ans j'ai des défilés déjà très très
jeune et à 8 ans effectivement vous
étiez meneuse de revue pour un spectacle
ça plaît c'est peut-être pas le mot non
j'étais chorégraphe et d'un groupe
d'enfants que j'avais créé avec ma
meilleure amie qui s'appelait le baby
show et on était une dizaine de petits
de 4 à 13 ans et je faisais les
chorégraphies puis avec les copines je
dessinais les modèles et c'est les
mamans qui faisait les vêtements et puis
on se produisait dans les arbres de noël
on les comités etc et on s'amusait
beaucoup on avait un gentil leur poche
en vous et où il y avait du temps va pas
d'elza on faisait tous les dessins
animés de l'époque il y avait dû
vanessa paradis joe le taxi fait plein
de choses il ya neuf ans fait votre
première comédie musicale s'appelait
chemisier rose et paniers blanc est
votre première émission de télé à l'âge
de 9 ans salle entendu sur série club la
première séverine club
oui alors après l'âge de 14 ans le grand
moment est arrivé
[Musique]
vous avez rencontré patrick sabatier
13 ans 13 ans à rennes je suis désolé je
peux pas en mettre trop casque après 91
13 ans ouais et en fait on a une grande
surprise parce que mes petits camarades
du baby sion avait fait ce cadeau tout
simplement d'écrire à sabatier et et de
décès nous faire inviter pour pour ce
grand show qui à l'époque était enfin
pour nous c'était le rêve quoi et
finalement un jour on a reçu un coup de
fil à la maison et puis j'entends voilà
bon c'est tout ça à une touche et ouais
c'est ça ouais et puis finalement je
pense du mais voilà on vous appelle de
la métropole et tout mais je suis mais
non mais vous rigolez tout ça que
j'appelle papa papa papa il ya un coup
de fil de la métropole et puissante en
d'un décalage donc tout de suite me suis
dit bon l'habitude c'est est ce que oui
on il ya un décalage entre les
communications parisienne et
réunionnaises et finalement état rhéaume
on a un peu discuté pu me dire attends
je crois que vais je crois que le rêve
les arrivées voilà tu vas tous à la une
ils ont fait venir dix enfants on
n'avait jamais pris l'avion et c'était
génial parce que les mamans elles sont
venues et tout et c'était même un
week-end de rêve vous avez quelque chose
patrick sabatier lendemain c'était moi
j'aimais bien du biogaz c'était génial
on est si on était 15 pers
le local qu'à faire venir voile et c'est
tout à l'âge de 15 ans vous décidez vos
parents à venir s'installer en train de
16 ans encore mieux oui on a tout quitté
là bas et on est venu à l'arrêt enfin on
est venus de la réunion donc ma mère a
tout abandonné mon père a tout abandonné
il savait que c'était ma passion et
celle de mon petit frère aussi et c'est
pour ça que ben merci merci merci et
aujourd'hui je suis contente parce que
bon j'ai j'ai pas réussi mais disons que
je me dis enfin j'essaye de mettre un
schéma dans la tête tous les gens me
dire qu'il ya quarante mille marché je
viens de monter le premier publié sur la
première marche
et puis j'espère qu'ils sont contents
ils n'ont jamais dit mais aussi vrai que
ce n'était pas facile en arrivant à
paris dit on a vécu beaucoup de galères
on n'avait pas de connexion on avait un
producteur qui s'avérait être véreux et
sans l'a si bien plus tard mais bon
c'est il fallait que je passe par là
pour aujourd'hui vivre
expérience que je en train de vivre
alors maintenant vous présentez fans de
le samedi matin sur m6 et vous êtes
parfois très fan des stars de l'émission
on va la presse people s'est fait l'écho
de quelques stars dont vous êtes devenu
très fan bon bah oui peut-être devoir
vous voit en photo avec un certain
nombre de vedettes de la chanson dans
des journaux que personne n'a voulu en
général vr mais c'est normal vous les
fréquentes et donc c'est normal qu'à un
moment vous tombiez oui font partie de
mon métier c'est une rencontre au
quotidien c'est pas forcément d amour
c'est aussi des alignerait la plupart du
temps c est le problème
vous avez souffert de ça des photos dans
la presse people on vous voyez les gens
disent ou font un chanteur oui j'avais
les mêmes souffert jamais les mêmes
bruits parce que heureusement que j'ai
plein de fréquentation sinon ce serait
triste et monotone comme religion mais
oui j'en ai souffert et un moment j'en
ai vraiment eu ras-le-bol
c'est pour ça que c'était aller raconter
vos malheurs au dalaï lama pas raconter
mes dix ont trouvé du réconfort auprès
du dalaï lama
on va regarder magnéto serge
[Musique]
pour deux mois
j'ai
la fois
quoi j'ai dans le coeur
j'ai attendu 48 heures d'avoir d'avoir
rendez vous avec le dalaï lama
enfin 48 heures c'est rien ouais c'était
des années et des années
lui est arrivé très souriant vous étiez
un peu un peu nerveuse un peu c'était
c'était trois quarts d'heure dans une
salle où j'étais tétanisée j'avais peur
je faisais alors j'avais la cata avec
moi que j'avais bien enroulé etc
le chap et je vous dis mais qu'est ce
que je vais faire il ya une façon de la
déroulé quand on arrive devant lui et
tous et je suis arrivé je les ai vus
mais j'y croyais pas et j'ai regardé
ciel et j'ai remercié mondiaux à moi
quoi je me suis mais merci c'est
tellement beau cadeau il était souriant
vous le mets beaucoup de la veille la
main oui parce que c'est un soleil il
vous réconforte c'est ainsi que moi
quand j'étais avec lui je voulais pas
lâcher du regard parce que j'avais
l'impression que si je regardais le
rideau d'à côté j'allais rater quelque
chose et je voulais pas rater une
seconde c'est tellement écran contre ce
monsieur et je les regarde et je
l'écouté en fait tu buvais toutes ces
paroles et c'était ça ma faim bien
terrible et je suis revenu et finalement
ça faire don à vendredi où il avait posé
la question essentielle dalaï lama fait
pas le voyage pour rien ne fait pas les
25000 km pour rien non j'avais envie qui
met l avons envie que le dalaï lama le
l'éclair un petit peu sur ces problèmes
et elle dit au dalaï lama
quelle attitude adopter adopter face à
ce que le bonheur semble déranger
on m'a reproché mon affection pour des
personnes célèbres insinuant que jean
calculer les effets bénéfiques
vous avez dire au dalaï lama que
finalement on pensait qu'ils étaient
dans voici avec des chanteurs pour faire
avancer votre carrière
on m'a reproché mon affection pour les
personnes célèbres
sinon j'aurais parlé comment la presse
son échelle alors ça c'est entre
guillemets ça c'est wells entre
guillemets mais c'est la presse qui le
dit mais ceci dit quand je suis allé le
voir oui je lui ai demandé de deux en
fait de m'éclairer sur cette attitude
que je dois avoir face à des gens qui ne
cherchent qu à me détruire
et justement s'attaque à ma vie privée a
raconté des ragots sans même me
connaître et à porter un jugement
quelconque sur moi alors qu'ils nous
jamais adressé la passe d'être pris
entre mais moi ça me avec un chanteur
s'entendait animatrice de télé salariale
à peine avant le dalaï lama pour lui
raconter ça que j'étais à l'armée j'ai
pas fait que ce nom mais ça c'est
l'occasion qui fait le larron
cela veut dire qu'il m'a appris beaucoup
de son temps il fallait voir directeur
de voici directement
j'avais envie de faire le voyage vous
avez dit c'est vrai que mon métier
m'oblige à côtoyer beaucoup d'artistes
oui mais oui moi comme n'importe quel
film arrive de tomber amoureuse mais
parce que j'ai une fille comme toutes
les autres a bien entendu qui n'est pas
tant enfin dès lors le dalaï lama
qu'est ce que vous croyez qu'il a
répondu c'est à dire que c'est pas
facile comme question dans voici allocs
danielle mitterrand on l'a vu avec
richard jr
c'est pas simple pour lui non plus pas
moins six mois ils aiment les dix jeux
d'éveil l'abattoir l écoute ta propre la
vie là bas moi j'aime le dalaï lama
depuis qu'il est avec richard g ouais
uniquement la compassion à séverine le
pardon le pardon alors c'est vrai que
vous dites avec le dalaï lama finalement
on a beaucoup ri oui est-ce qu'ils ont
trahi rigole tout le temps lavage de
dire à dharamsala c'est de tirer sur le
joueur
il a tellement d'énergie qui il vous en
donne voilà enfin c'est ce que j'ai
ressenti et non il ya trop de temps les
franquine là bas lui aussi il faut dire
les bémols à huy dans son monastère et
tout mais bon c'est pas si simple que ça
quand on était en parler de ce qui était
en train de faire les chinois à cette
époque c'était pas du tout drôle non et
bon bref quoi qu'on dise c'était
peut-être une rencontre ego la rigolote
c'était de la rigolade que peut-être
pour des gens en tout cas pour moi ça a
été ça a été très vite vous êtes rentré
différentes mûri je pense vous dites
maintenant je vais voir des bébés à
condition de trouver le papa tout à fait
bien on va lancer un appel pour trouver
à 40 ans élève mais seuls et sans enfant
non merci
ah non je ne serai plus là ouais tu
portrait pas de pas avoir des enfants
pas en tout cas j'en adopterai mais je
ne supporterais pas de vous cherchez
vous êtes à la télé si vous voulez
lancer un appel dit exactement le genre
d'homme que vous voulez mais elle est
déjà la télé tout le temps elle en a
bien sûr même si certains droits devant
cet appel c'est pas le même genre
un homme qui mène normal j'ai devant moi
grand chose au melon avec des cheveux ça
m'est égal avec damon est comme ça et
puis il sort des
[Applaudissements]
c'est donc si vous cherchez une petite
bruine où il avait trouvé et larusso
j'ai lancé un appel pour la russie la
semaine dernière s'est fiancé vendredi à
montceau avec le mec des boys band un
type très sympa ils se sont fiancés
vendredi non mais ça marche très bien
mais cherchait un papa pour aurillac
séverine est ce que vous avez toujours
le petit mouchoir en papier que vous a
donné le dalaï lama
oui vous l'avez sur vous bien protégé
non pas sur moi à la maison c'est quoi
une mx-5 kleenex couvent est malade on
attendait quand j'avais perdu ici excuse
moi excusez moi aurait permis c'est très
bien c'est symbolique pour moi c'est ça
mais oblige c'est pas celui-là ça ne
fait pas été bien mis en lieu sûr et il
était très beau bien alors vous sortez
un parfum qui s'appelle les enfants du
soleil
oui voilà vous à le faire circuler on va
tous le renifler un petit peu patient
josiah que tu sais un faut dire que
peut-être pas de données à l'échelle
c'est pas comme ça mais si on s'entraîne
et des frites et il me ressemble
voilà c'est moi qui ai choisi les
ingrédients c'est pas mal ses
citronniers on peut dire fait c'est
fruité s'effriter ces idiots comme ça
avec vous aimez d origine voilà sept
séverine ferrer mine de rien elle vole
dalaï lama et quand vous revenez vous
faites un parfum vous donnez 10 francs
par flacon la croix rouge parce que je
trouve ça normal ça normal on
merci à ceux qui achètent le parfum sa
souveraineté attention oui bon attention
c'est quoi ces mais sur quoi
bah c'est sûr les femmes ah ah ouais
mais qui est-ce qui répondent tout le
monde à mon attention millions d'humains
tout s'enchaîne euros les stores et
vidéo ce sont les ahmadis télécom a figé
les messieurs dernier
le lacie
un dernier à mais ça c'est mon domaine
ouais à l'habitude autant l'histoire de
l'art j'ai du mal
autant var y est je suis top on continue
[Musique]
bah oui oui paullo laisse tourner vivier
jeu était bonne puisque tout le monde a
répondu vous nous éclairer
[Musique]
l'écart prix ça s'appelle reviens c'est
pour les flammes par trinh-duc si vous
ne saviez continue sa chambre au diable
oui or au diable troisième chanson
didier la laisse pas tomber elle est si
fragile femme libérée qui didier marie
claire
[Musique]
continuer avec sa flotte est certaine si
on continue comme ça c'est un peu nul
vous répondez pas de la cendre là c'est
bien je connais ses chansons et le
l'interprète faisait trop pourquoi on
les a coupés des lieux
plus léger que la cendre de la sicav est
élevé chez norma ça montre c'est
extrêmement difficile les gens tu perds
ton temps
dans ce teaser donné l'année dernière ça
a été aujourd'hui c'était beau c'était
maurane véronique sanson les autres et
liane foly cette région tu étais quai
comme un italien vanity l'amour et du
vent
la banque dans les limites y el motor
cinquième chanson dédiée ce et vous
présente fin des années 80
4 nages et sans complexe ces femmes 400
vaches mangent dernier
allez
c'est michel dernier qui va d'aller le
parfum de séverine ferrer c'est le
premier prix je vais plus des 10 bals
jaxa
numéro 6 très très facile plus facile
aux blagues je suis sympa là je viens
fall julien clerc julien clerc femmes je
vous aime les jolies chansons tu vas te
n'est pas d'aider celles là il progresse
très vite j'ai cru comprendre que
c'étaient des ministres consacré aux
femmes tout le montage tel talent est la
parité quoi l'arrivée on continue alors
si bédié
c'est la main
et
[Applaudissements]
mais ton avis de fès 30
m
[Musique]
j'ai senti mes canons c'était dans les
pétroleuses c'est sinon je me suis le
plus d'un an je crois que c'était la
guerre au mexique
alors on continue avec le 9e ah ça c'est
ça ressemble à 10 francs soit fait
sa mère bravo
votez charlotte reinhardt à ma lunette
bravo dixième et dernière chanson didier
mécanique
[Applaudissements]
teinté faces in the blind test ce soir
pas pour vous j'ai pris tous non je
déconne et tout je me suis pas rapide
c'est pas pour ça que je vous dis au
revoir mais je vous remercie d'être
venus en tous les cas c'est gentil ça me
fait très plaisir que je vais mais je
vous remercie
ce trésor êtes là c'est vrai c'est une
tête juridique sérieux bond
cet amour ben j'ai toujours beaucoup
aimé michel l'origine on veut quelqu'un
j'arrive pas à voir qui y voit le dalaï
lama et c'est possible c'est fait les ya
là un transfert avec l'agent orange il
va très très bien
ouais il est bien dans l'allier jeu
super de boer il est beau dans la malice
et ça c'est bernard lama et ça c'est de
la m
vous savez ce que vous racontez le
dernier de la main quand il est venu à
paris là il est venu à l'assemblée
mais vous savez à l'époque
quelle différence il ya entre un
monastère tibétain et le paris
saint-germain aucune dans les deux cas
il ya dix années à la main c'est pas
vrai actuellement il marche bien on va
mettre des wii
tant pis pour le dalaï lama michèle
gillet au revoir parce qu'on me disait
dans l'oreillette que vous vouliez d'y
aller mais s'ils voulaient rester vous
êtes la bienvenue voulez je vous
présentais un prix goncourt
oui non mais oui bien sûr toujours des
prix goncourt oui je reconnais un prix
goncourt dans j'en ai un qui est bien
bon alors je reste maintenant j'en ai un
qui est bien c'est très bizarre vous
restiez en plus et j'accueille
maintenant pjak au resto
attention la marche c'était un truc ici
c'est tous les avis kings sandwich
j'suis con mais ça va pas trop mal
pas trop mal bien alors vous connaissez
andré santini michèle bernier qui a un
film s'appelle vivre nous de camille de
casabianca qui va sortir qu'on peut voir
sur scène dans une pièce que j'ai vu et
dont je dis du peu à peu près deux ans
et plus grand bien de cette émission on
va finir par croire que c'est sa peine
jeudi francis lalanne voilà linda hardy
d'abord vous connaissez michèle laroque
et séverine ferrer soit dans les loges à
l'existant ou bien alors vous êtes
journaliste ouais vous avez travaillé
aux nouvelles littéraires dépens de jean
françois kahn à l'express oui
et aujourd'hui vous travaillez en fait
seulement en tant que journaliste bien
entendu à seulement au canard enchaîné
ou sous le pseudonyme de l'udc des
signes oui vous occuper de la danse oui
j'exécute voilà vous êtes un spécialiste
de la danse et d'ailleurs vous dansez
très bien oui mais j'ai dansé chez vous
et non pas le regard des magnétos
[Musique]
on
demont
[Musique]
voilà c'était bien tomber ce taux
bientôt besco dans une émission qui
s'appelait bain de minuit qui était sur
la chaîne défunte sur l'a5
c'est formidable oui mais j'avais danse
et giselle aussi en partie vous aurez
des référés quand ça dépend noir ou
blanc ou et très peu d'ong lemieux blanc
moi je sue formidable c'est quand même
un des rares moments où on voit un prix
goncourt en tutu images étaient encore
que prix médicis à ce moment là oui mais
c'est pour ça vous seriez prêt à
l'enrôler de l'école est cachée serait
doublé alors désormais effectivement
vous êtes surtout écrivain oms en effet
d'ici donc primé 10 686 juste avant ça
avec les funérailles de la sardine
200000 exemplaires d'un prix goncourt en
91 avec les filles du calvaire
trois cent cinquante mille exemplaires
est en ce moment alors là bras le livre
du moment c'est des petites mazari mais
là c'est chez grasset wish bras oui oui
la maison de commerce et grâce à la
maison de commerce et grasse et voilà
très bonnes ventes sur ça se maintient
ouais ça se maintient c'est dur la
condition d'écrivain oui
ouais ouais je crois oui mais très
exaltant et vous vivez de vos livres là
maintenant oui enfin un peu lieu un peu
de ma danse aussi
non parce qu'à un moment donné nos
coudes et des dames très riche comme ça
qui vous qui vous recevez dans la chatte
est un peu façon valant un peu gigolo
l'armée gigolo bien ah ben non on a de
bonnes maisons où on sait nourrir oui
arrive quand même là l'époque des
truffes ou du caviar il faut quand même
c'est là maintenant vous pouvez
continuer à continuer quand même à ben
il ya quand même une vie mondaine 8,9 en
oeuvre des vieilles dames
comment je ne vis pas débat nous vendre
et dames
vous étiez invité dans des vaches est
toujours à éviter vous êtes invités non
oui tous invités oui bon je préfère des
gens qui vous servent plutôt d hamlet
aux truffes ou un peu de caviar que des
gens qui vous donne la blanquette de
veau des familles encore que j'aime
beaucoup la blanquette de veau
ça rejoint mazars qui était quand même
un drôle de gigolo oui c'est un côté
amusant de la vie non maison leroy crois
qu'on les favoris dans les nièces de
mazarin petit mazarine y'avait marie
lambert deux noms marie et l'amoureuse
grande amoureuse louis xiv voulait
l'épouser
oui oui oui elle était très elle est
sans doute celle qui de la plus moderne
c'est-à-dire qu'elle ressemblait à un
petit chevreau très mince un peu genre
audrey hepburn ou voyait les salières
tout ça très belles perles de jules
dents mais tout à fait le contre le
contre pied de ce qu'étaient les beautés
alors qu'ils étaient déboutés grâce on
aimait bien s'endormir sur le mastic et
donc il fallait des coulées beauté un
peu plus lent travail et elle pas du
tout non absolument audrey hepburn 78
jusqu'à 70 ça un peu fonctionné mais il
ya un truc que j'ai pas compris dans ce
bouquin son mari parce qu'après il
quitte la fin ne se marie pas avec louis
xiv nom et elle poliquin colonna oui un
prince koloni et se pratiquer la voile
ce prince que le nain découvre que sa
femme ait vieilli ouais ça veut dire que
louis xiv avait pas essayer voulait
l'épouser sans avoir essayé à l'époque
fait très difficile oui ça c'est que
mardi son oui c'est un gros lourdaud
louis xiv c'est elle qui l'a un peu des
salles et dans le genre qui lui a pris
un petit peu les choses amoureux de la
belle conversation le gel il savoir de
dire les des choses qui vous débris d'un
peu le coeur et puis peut-être que je ne
sais pas peut-être que ça ne s'est pas
fait par les voies naturelles alors
l'appel l'autre alors été sûr qu'elle
faisait davantage alkhalaf faisait les
avantages au roi mais après avoir été
mariée ouais non légales et pas avec
cette petite préciosité de virginité
c'était un petit bijou qu'il fallait
garder surtout chez des italiens ne
faisais pas je peux enfin monstre on
peut faire derrière un rideau entre deux
portes qui bonjour par le bas bonjour
par le bape qui vont jour par le bar
clinton willington par le match mais
c'est vrai qu'elle procurait alors celle
là où l'un des maîtresses
roy elle procure est non lumpp était
était la plus délurée elle était une
joueuse effréné elle était très
intelligente et elle avait un salon et
en même temps c'était une sorte de
merteuil aller mais bien la personne qui
gouvernait la maîtresse du roi
gouvernait le roi donc quand elle n'a
plus pu gouverner avec sa langue elle a
gouverné par les maîtresses et
évidemment mais ça n'a jamais marché
puisque le roi est tombé tout de suite
amoureux de la vallière c'est encore
comme ça non impossible c'est impossible
non c'est plus possible n'a jamais
existé d'ailleurs alors hortense elle
donc c est légataire c'est mon pas
toutes les fermes en face à elle me fait
marrer parce que hortense est la plus
sympathique
oui elle s'est mariée avec
lc marie-jeanne richelieu qui à capri là
qui a pris le nom de ma de mazara alors
lui il avait une drôle de bizarreries
quand même un oui oui mais il est un peu
un peu toc et je prenais pour une tulipe
oui oui oui ça faisait reposer comme une
bulle et il n'a jamais aimé qu il n'a
jamais aimé qu'une femme c'était sa
femme ce qui était très triste pour elle
mais
et quand elle est morte il est resté dix
ans elle a promené dans toute la france
un peu comme jane la folle avec le
cercueil derrière et on leur rende le
soir ou météores tance dans son cercueil
dans un petit oratoire bilan matin à pau
repartait les vapeurs y avait quand même
des petits pages très jolie toussaint
sont noirs comme ça avec des petits
collants très serré enfin tout ça
c'était quand même très folies bergère
non c'était sympa mais comment quand on
vit votre bouquin parce que le prince de
conti coucher avec sa soeur lui n'ont
rien qui peut oui enfin enfin est il le
prétendait il le prétendait à l'époque
c'était condé aussi le prétendait
on pouvait coucher avec sa soeur bas
encore aujourd'hui
non vous voyez lansargues et une seule
vous ne vous seriez pas avec n
non mais moi j'aurai un frère je
coucherais avec lui alors ça je ne ferai
pas
oui évidemment sk mieux-être et 18e
n'ont pas les huitièmes
entrée entièrement pharaonique vous
continueriez paris votre frère vous
basse argent n'est pas c'est quoi ça
vous voulez va l'avoir
non je sais pas je suis quand même assez
surpris de ce fait je pense que le 19e
siècle a vraiment mis le le boisseau sur
sur ce tous libertinage parce que nous
on est désenchanté la viola la
révolution a amené les âmes nobles et
pur et sain prem's et ça avant le croyez
à rien oui continuer comme ça il y avait
des petits zabé en perruque mais qui
disait la messe mais il est des pousses
du de l'yonne qui couchait que son
beau-fils
oui en sandwich avec sa fille sympa non
mais j'ai pris la petite chronique parce
qu'il fallait quand même faire rire les
gens pea musée allemand salue leur
montrer leur pub je m'excuse
il va vous culbuter et en même temps il
va perdre un siège
bon on va rester dans les jeux de salon
la joue faire un petit anti portrait
chinois
merde bougez pas
[Musique]
vous connaissez le portrait chinois non
je connais pas moi aussi le portrait
chinois c'est un jeu qui est vieux comme
on dit si vous étiez une fleur alors
vous dites sur un vieux autistes ou des
lentilles porter chinois c'est autre
chose
ah bon celle inverse avant jeudi si vous
étiez à défaut vous seriez quoi comme
défaut à bojan serions encore mais vous
allez me reposer après justine maladie
enfin je serai la coqueluche fut rien si
vous étiez un accident circulation si
vous étiez une perversion la pire vite
une guerre en dentelle un dictateur papy
nash est une arme de pacotille un
supplice chinois une cicatrice d'amour
si vous étiez un assassin
landru parce qu'il aimait les femmes si
vous étiez un [ __ ] vous pas mal non
[Applaudissements]
j'accueille maintenant
un invité exceptionnel le dalaï lama
[Applaudissements]
leila l'instant
et l'avenir j'accueille david douillet
fort de laisser tout le monde bat
maintenant oui là maintenant oui vous
étiez en coulisses exactement je parlais
tout le monde très bien je vais essayer
de me voir souvent plus qu'ils photo il
sait pas si c'est bien fait une connerie
ce fort michèle bernier david metai
poids lourds francis lalanne linda bien
alors david douillet soir - quatre fois
champion du monde et champion olympique
vous n'êtes pas mal vous êtes parent la
11e édition des pièces jaunes
oui qui date qui dure jusqu'au 29
janvier 2011 si vous êtes des pièces
jaunes voilà je vous ai préparé la
petite tirelire
si vous avez des pièces jaunes voilà que
c'est comme ça donc vous mettez des
pièces jaunes d'oeufs dans ma journée
bon réflexe je vais passer la petite
once upon the douillet ben ouais c'est
pas vraiment pu me tenez bon oui
toujours aimé les pièces jaunes alors
donc non pourquoi il ya cette opération
pièces jaunes c'est parce qu'il ya 8000
enfants qui sont hospitalisés chaque
jour et sur les sources sur les 8000 il
y en a deux mille qu'il faut au moins un
mois d'hôpital et donc pour améliorer la
qualité du séjour hospitalier de ses
enfants et à l'opération pièces jaunes
ont calé tirelire comme celle qui est en
train de passer parmi vous
c'est un peu ris orangis y aller thierry
rey qui s'étire liens dans les biberons
squillaci était l'époux de la guerre la
marraine de l'opération
c'est bernadette chirac et vous avez
déclaré
même si c'était madame je spa je
m'investirai quand même bah oui c'est
pas une question de ont fait une
association politique et l'histoire
alors ça ça n'a rien à voir bien sûr
mais en même temps vous êtes comme
chiraquien bas parce que c'est parce que
je les aime bien en tant qu elle non
mais je sais vous êtes chirac un essai
très malin vous allez voir images chocs
david douillet a déclaré quand tu es
gamin que tu gagnes un championnat tu
reçois toujours un courrier de la mairie
de paris
et ça de suite toute ta carrière cirque
la mairie de paris quand vous gagnez
vous envoie une petite la veille
systématiquement ça continue toujours je
crois
oui une petite lettre de félicitations
depuis qu'on est tout petit il avait
habité à bouffer mêmes arguments en
cours c'est sympa gentil il ya mon
service de on n'est pas président saint
lazare
non ne veut pas voter pour lui
évidemment vous avez mangé des truffes
non non blanches devant ça bien comme ça
un peu en suisse
j'ai pas trouvé très agréable ouais
parce que évidemment mais je n'aime pas
beaucoup les buveurs de bière
j'aime bien la bière de temps en temps
mais pas sur le bien et puis tiens dans
une timbale comme ça c'est un peu
rustique voulait dire oui enfin nous
maintenons parce qu'on a l'impression
que ils vous donnent ils vous flanque il
m'avait 20 et qui lui prend sa petite
bien parce qu'ils haïssent garde
l'estomac alors notre engagement
politique dont vous êtes chiraquien
l'espère pour ça évidemment outre les
pièces jaunes a toujours bien compris
bravo parents étaient plutôt plutôt
socialiste pas oui alors david douillet
vous avez été élevé par votre grand mère
voulait faire du judo et votre grand
mère vous a dit la communion solennelle
d'abord ouais ben c'était ça dans l'été
ça la cambrousse quand même à faire
oublier joe kay c'est un peu raté j'ai
perdu il est choqué mais enfin je veux
dire quand même que david douillet ce
qu'il faut savoir c'est que il faisait
56 cm et 4 kg 5 à la naissance bogies go
et à 10 en examen m 80 me disais il ya
14 ans 1 m 85 et maintenant ils
s'arrêtent pas d'accord alors il disait
c'est terrible d'ailleurs parce que ces
10 et j'étais grand baie les ont
regardés comme une bête curieuse était
si un peu complexé quoi parce qu'on
disait un peu complet il est plus grands
alors il est plus bête c'est vrai
d'ailleurs que les gens c'est quelque
chose c'est vrai c'est assez les gens
contre les jambes sont en plus ils sont
grands plus son talent de classe mais
pas la récréation une histoire assez pas
ça en fait ce que étant donné qu'on est
con on est grand en taille on a toujours
l'impression de plus âgés les gens qui
vous côtoient sans se voir votre âge
vous exiler 10 est forcément un décalage
par rapport à ce qu'on a à l'intérieur
et vous pensiez diop
enfin avec les filles c'était dur sinon
oui aussi oui parce que parce que quand
quand une fille à ses premiers à ses
premiers amours on n'a pas forcément
envie de se retrouver avec la grande
gigue de la classe c'est mignon et une
petite histoire même ça explique leur
explique les choses et gauche maladroit
et un peu toujours les filles c'est le
premier pas quoi oui aussi qu'à se
croiser deux français mais ça ça fait un
fait divers aix en provence a fait un
film de kayak cette histoire de calmer
gabrielle russier oui
non mais ça pas été aussi loin mourir
d'aimer
bravo vous avez été découvert par jean
luc rougé qui était le premier champion
du monde de judo français et lui dès
qu'il vous a vus il a dit
vous avez inscrit à l'insep tout de
suite face dès qu'on a fait un petit
combat ensemble parce que tout de suite
il a repéré le physique et aider kim a
eu entre ses mains un celi celui là à
voir quelques images de votre carrière
magnéto serge
[Musique]
mais pas demain
mais
il y a
ça donne
sirois que
[Musique]
et
k
mme et m
[Musique]
e
[Applaudissements]
m
champion du monde et champion olympique
alors vous dites à le combat quand tu le
perds ça représente la mort quand tu
entres sur le tapis tu sais qu'il y aura
un mort est un vivant et ça ressemble un
peu aux gladiateurs hausse à ce point
dacquois oui c'est une simulation c'est
une simulation d'un combat de
gladiateurs quand quand un athlète a
peur et qu'il a le trac et qu'il est
bloqué c'est c'est cette espèce de peur
ancestrale qui qui à l'intérieur du type
et ses skis comme ça réellement alors il
ya un truc vous avez en commun florence
arthaud est michelle lang
présentement je le fais pas exprès mais
vous avez un accident causé cet accident
en septembre 96 et ça vous a pas empêché
c'est assez étonnant en 97
deux ans après donc d'avoir votre
quatrième titre mondial
en fait j'ai positive et l'histoire quoi
tout simplement ouais faut avoir un
sacré mental quand même parce que bat
pas plus que quand on aime son métier
quand on a une passion dévorante ça
passe tout seul
quoi il avait un sacré mental ça
formidable chage quand quand on se
retrouve dans une chaise roulante au
mois de septembre et que le un an plus
tard il faut être sur un tatami et
essayer de gagner
c'est génial comme comme objectif et ça
s'est joué à peu de choses je les
réussis cette extraordinaire ce que vous
préférez être challenger systématique
systématiquement à dire que l'un des
titres fait leurs achats flotte dont je
fonctionne comme ça c'est à dire que je
on est champion du monde une seule
journée pas la veille ni lendemain c'est
à dire que dès que la journée terminée
les compteurs sont remis à zéro et c'est
génial parce que on est toujours en
position de daudzaï d'heure quand je me
suis jamais placé comme étant le tenant
du titre le type qui gagne xx x
parce que si j'avais fait ça je pense
que je serais passé à côté de plein de
détails qui sont importants justement
pour refaire une victoire derrière donc
systématiquement jeu
je ferme le tiroir la médaille ranger
s'est terminée à nouveau je deviens
voilà champion olympique aussi c'était
vous disiez que ce soir là vous avez
vous sentiez très très mal parce que
vous avez une espèce d'impression d'être
allé au bout de ce que vous pouvez
c'était le dernier titre qui me manquait
et l'âge arrivé au bout d'un chemin
je n'ai plus rien à dire à gravir j'ai
pu montagne j'ai plus rien tout sommet
donc pour moi c'était ça a été le vide
quoi j'avais plus quoi faire
est ce que j'allais continuer ou pas
j'avais une motivation et l'accident de
moto qui arrivait juste derrière en fait
vous aider ses cales cet accident parce
que vous êtes debout longtemps ça vous
fait marrer et toujours vers les pôles
vous décevra soir c'est pour la voiture
vous avez pensé tout arrêter à un moment
en tout plusieurs fois meilleur fois
plusieurs fois c'est pour aller chercher
un titre ça demande un travail
titanesque et et bien je suis un homme
j'ai mes faiblesses mais ô mes bas et
souvent ben je suis au bord d'arrêter
tellement c'est dur
et puis il ya toujours la petite flamme
qui vous raccroche l'intellectuel à
sydney qui vous motive norway geci net
il motive mais fauché ou leur pull à col
roulé là restinclières lettre la même
hauteur 4 mai
ça reste difficile sydney où
effectivement c'est un défi
extraordinaire mais est-ce que je vais
être capable de le supporter j'en sais
rien quand on vous traite de champion
des médias ça vous énerve ouvrir parce
que je le conçois pas comme ça moi je
quand je fais quelqu'un quelque part
c'est que j'ai envie d'y aller mais je
vais utiliser votre notoriété pour les
pièces jaunes et j'ai dit en commençant
à quel point c'était utile parce que
c'est vrai que tant qu'on a pas vu un
enfant dans un hosto on a du mal à
comprendre mais quand on l'a vu on
comprend donc c'est utile vous utilisez
pour les pièces jaunes mais vous l'avez
aussi j'ai beaucoup utilisé pour la pub
votre notoriété pas pour la pub surtout
pour m'amuser au départ et après ça
déclenche alors on s'aperçoit que ça
déclenche et s'est fêlé pu pour
mitsubishi pour danone gerflor ce n'est
de la flore je vous présente les
nouvelles d'ap
elles sont toujours au toit des il est
là
c'est je me suis vraiment beaucoup amusé
parce que ray c'est la première fois je
m'étais parce que j'étais pas tout nu
j'ai un petit string sûr que c'est vrai
ça il a fait aussi la première fois
qu'on me ashton
c'est spécial et chauffants l'hiver mais
le problème c'est que si dans nos sports
olympiques
on avait la chance de gagner autant
d'argent dans d'autres sports et je
jalouse pas ces gens là au contraire
tant mieux pour eux ce serait bien mais
nous pour l'un pic on est un peu obligé
de mettre du beurre dans les épinards et
on a un gîte passait plus par là que les
autres les autres y gagner pognon il le
faut c'est we r d art est l'heure pour
ce qui vont avec un point noir avec
cette histoire de travail store quoi oui
bah ça ça a été un peu mieux sur le pot
abba complètement parce que quand on a
confiance en rapporte raconter son
histoire en deux mots parce que comment
est ce qu'on la connaît pas on veut on
est toujours au nom de quoi
voilà vous êtes embringuée dans une
histoire vous étiez associés dans une
agence de voyage et vous à société des
escrocs cessa pas de pas les escrocs
mais en tout cas ils ont été légers dans
l'histoire et en fait on s'est aperçu
très vite que l'histoire était pas
viable moi je me suis rendu compte et
tout de suite je voulais arrêter le
système voilà c'est tout ce que je
reproche c'est que c'est un manque de
clark de clarté au départ est donné tu
es donc le piège il est là quoi c'est
tout c'est quand c'est quelqu'un vous
connaissez bien un ami on est toujours
mené face à sion
ça va rendre sa confiance passait tous
merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
alors on doit ce fait le tour avec le kg
les lacets quoi les dates des grandes
villes abbas et dans ça sera dans une
semaine et est là on va faire toutes les
grandes villes
on va terminer par avignon dimanche soir
et j'espère que ça va être aussi génial
que l'année dernière parce qu'il y avait
une grosse monopolisation de 43 millions
de sportive un break en place des
classes des centristes de partager les
biens et 10 francs 1
comment on peut donner les pièces de
différentes surtout dans l'est plusieurs
typhons surtout les pièces difficiles
puis même ceux des billets qui
encombrent la serbie au 6 juillet jour
du casse et il faut les déposer à la
poste parce que oui j'ai plein de gens
qui me disent on va vous donner non
c'est pas moi c'est pas nous c'est la
presse voit la salade 17 mille bureaux
de poste qui les reçoivent bien voilà
nous arrivons au terme de cette émission
je vais remercier d'abord si elles sont
ces des sans papiers
et sensible
m
mais
donc david douillet en la vie les pièces
jaunes
même les billets john a et vous je vous
remercie aussi d'être venu ici ce soir
donc le fils s'appelle vive nous oui à
il sort le 26 il sort le 26 à dieudo il
ya emmanuelle devos à camille de
casabianca à thibault de montalembert et
thibault de montalembert et c'est un
film donc de camille de casabianca oui
et c'est rigolo comme des chiens
andré santini dv6 et des lanternes merci
andré donc c'est tous les experts nous
raconte des histoire va commencer avec
les grecs vous en parlait d'ailleurs il
y avait que platon qui a été trompé par
denis de syracuse italie laisser sa peau
voilà mal points puis la série ne faire
qu on retrouve tous les samedis dans fan
de sur m6le parfois ils s'appellent les
enfants du soleil sont très bons merci
séverine pierre combescot les petites
mazarine chez grasset
[Applaudissements]
et michèle laroque épouse moi ni siège
avec vincent perez daries marin
merci à tous et à la semaine prochaine
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ouais